All we'll live.
You called that a,
you get that bar and your teeth are you
good thing stick.
They stick those green belly meal bars.
So,
uh,
first of all,
man,
your documentary,
Icarus is a,
I see I say that wrong all the time.
I say a chorus,
but it's ICARUS.
ICARUS,
yeah.
That's the guy with the wings that flew
too close to the sun.
Exactly.
Um,
it's fucking amazing.
It's an amazing documentary.
Um,
uh,
I had contacted you,
we'd gone back and forth a little bit on
twitter and then I finally sat down and
watched it the other day and I was like,
Holy Shit.
The extent of the coverup and the,
the first of all for,
for folks who don't know what it's
about,
the documentary started off just kind of
about doping.
Right?
And then it became about the state
sponsored Russian doping program and
then it all imploded.
While you were doing the documentary,
the documentary,
how long did it take you to put this
together?
A three and a half years.
And so what was the initial idea behind
it?
So the initial idea,
I guess,
uh,
I'll,
I'll say it's a,
it's streaming on Netflix right now.
They've released it a month ago and uh,
the initial idea had come to me
essentially when Armstrong confessed and
I'd been a lifelong cycling fan and I
had followed him for,
you know,
my,
my whole journey with him.
And uh,
and what struck me the most about his
confession was that if you talk to
anybody outside of the sport,
they all thought that he got caught.
But the reality is,
is he actually never got caught.
I mean,
to this day this guy is passed,
500 anti-doping controls clean.
So I'm going,
wait,
not what's wrong with Armstrong?
What's wrong with this global
anti-doping system that they can't catch
the most tested athlete on planet earth?
And I'm going,
wait,
he's tested clean 500 times.
Who should we be mad at?
Should we be mad at Armstrong or should
we be upset at this system?
That is essentially making an athlete
not have a choice as to what they do or
not do.
If they actually want to have a
possibility of winning,
if the system itself is not able to
catch them,
well that's a big
factor,
right?
I mean that is really an important thing
to talk about it in the high level world
of cycling when they took away
Armstrong's victories in the Tour de
France.
I think the person who got who did not
test positive in any tests before that,
I think it was like 18th place.
Is that correct?
Someone I don't
remember exactly,
but yeah,
but there was,
there was no one and then even after a,
his confession,
if you remember how they get them to
confess as essentially the,
the feds come in on
a criminal investigation and they
basically go to all of his teammates
over the years that he had raised some
basically point guns at their head and
say,
Hey,
uh,
did you dope or did you not dope?
Now if you tell us that you doped and
that Armstrong doped,
you go free and we weren't going to
punish you,
but if you lie to us,
there's gonna be a price to pay.
And in doing that,
all of his teammates who did the exact
same thing that he did ratted him out in
exchange for their own immunity.
And um,
and the rest is history,
do it too,
right?
Like he was actually suing people that
were saying that he was doping and he
was going after them and threatening
them with lawsuits and which,
you know,
and that's,
you know why before I ever picked up a
camera,
um,
I had named the film Icarus and I had
named it icarus because of what I deemed
the Armstrong story,
which was a story of a guy who just kept
pushing the boundaries and pushing the
boundaries and pushing the boundaries
until he flew too close to the sun and
his wings burn and he plummeted to the
earth.
And that to me was the story of,
you know,
uh,
ambition that wouldn't stop and having
no filter on how far you went to win and
what you were willing to do and who you
were willing to destroy in that process
to win.
And to me,
um,
you know,
when you take the doping out of it,
that's,
you know,
uh,
the problem that,
you know,
I would have on a,
on a,
on a personal kind of level with the
lance of it that,
you know,
it's one thing if you're doing something
that everybody else is doing,
but it's another thing when you
literally are going out and destroying
other people's lives to,
um,
to try to protect your own lies.
Yeah.
I mean,
I kind of see his position,
I see how he got caught up in it and the
momentum of it all just sort of brought
them to this place where it was almost.
No,
there's no way to do it either,
you know,
you go after these people and try to
silence them or you come clean.
And eventually he was forced to come
clean.
You knew though.
Um,
and most people did that he was doing
something.
Yeah.
I mean,
I had
always felt that he was doing something.
Um,
but I also,
having been kind of deeply involved in
the sport,
believed that everybody else was doing
something also.
So his confession to me wasn't really
the shocker,
what was,
what was the shocker and what set me out
on this journey was like in the Public
Court of opinion and what you saw going
on in the news was it was essentially
like,
you know,
we've got Gadi,
we've got Al Capone,
we've got the ringleader,
we've got the,
you know,
the biggest criminal and the history of
sport essentially.
And we finally got him and to me it was
getting Al Capone
on tax evasion.
You didn't get him because the system
didn't work to get him.
And so I started looking at,
forget about cycling.
I was looking at what does this mean in
all sports?
What does this mean in terms of the
Olympics?
What does this mean in terms of
basketball and football and baseball
and,
and all these other sports.
If the most tested athlete on planet
earth can't be caught.
And um,
and that's what set me out on a to make
the film initially was to explore using
kind of just the Armstrong story as the
framework,
but to explore what was,
what was wrong with the Anti doping
system in sport and essentially use
myself as a,
as a human Guinea pig to explore that
and then along that way kind of show
whether or not this system worked and
then essentially present hypothetical's
about what could be done or what
couldn't be done.
Um,
and whether or not we as a society care,
uh,
about,
you know,
drug use in sport and,
and that was the original concept and
construct of the film.
Well,
drug use in sport is very complicated
because it's,
it's so prevalent and it's almost
impossible to separate the two when you
think about it,
particularly the Tour de France,
right?
And professional cycling.
I mean,
it is just a dirty sport.
Well,
I,
I think that,
um,
from what I know is over the last
several years,
it's really cleaned up quite a bit,
quite a lot.
Um,
and if you start looking at the times
also they've,
they've started to come down and slow
down,
um,
but I think that we're probably in a,
what I would call it,
I don't know,
a glory period,
uh,
between the science kind of catching up
to the cheaters in some way.
And then the cheaters basically figuring
out how to out science the science
again,
so they're in like a holding pattern,
I feel like in the world of cycling,
um,
at least that's going on to some extent.
You just get caught just a couple days
ago with a,
an engine in his bike.
Oh,
that's the new thing.
Yeah,
they're,
they're putting engines and bikes.
Um,
I've read that a,
they're now figuring out how to
replicate a epo,
withrow,
poblete and at the genetic level
basically how to make yourselves
naturally create more withrow po eaten.
So there's always going to be something
on that cusp of,
of medical technology.
Um,
and human evolution.
I'm trying to outsmart the system and
the testing.
So when you contacted the,
uh,
the Russian gentleman,
what was his name again?
Gregory.
Rich Chenko and Gregory is the guy and
he's right now in the witness protection
program.
Protective protective
custody.
Now how did you get ahold of him and how
did you set that up?
Because it was fascinating.
Once you shoot your ass full with like
100 different kinds of steroids.
I mean it was just how much,
how many different things did you take?
It took a lot
over how much of a period of about nine
months.
About nine months.
And in what had,
what had happened is,
is.
So I decided that I was gonna go on this
supersize me as journey into the world
of performance enhancing drugs and I
spend about a year doing all this
research,
uh,
shortly after Armstrong confesses,
which is 2013,
early 2013 and I actually picked up a
camera in May of 2014.
And,
and over this year I start talking to
all these scientists and I'm contacting
people on a global level and Switzerland
and Germany and the UK and all over the
US.
And essentially each one of these
scientists I'm asking,
I'm essentially the same questions.
I'm saying,
Hey,
do you believe they anti-doping system
in sport works?
And every single one of them said no,
and I said,
do you believe that you can catch an
athlete who is doping?
And every single one of them told me no.
I said,
do you believe that you could still
essentially do what Lance Armstrong did
and get away with it with the proper
advisors?
And every one of them said to me,
yes,
and then I would pose the question to
each one of these guys.
I said,
are you able,
would you have this knowledge to advise
me how to essentially a evade positive
detection?
And the vast majority of them said yes,
and I said,
but will you do that?
And they said no.
And they said the biggest variable was
it you've got to get your samples into a
water lab,
a World Anti Doping Agency lab.
And that becomes very difficult because
if you can just get your samples into
water lab,
amateur professional,
anybody,
right?
Well you can start figuring out all the,
you know,
loopholes and what you can do and what
you can't do.
If you can essentially know how to be
tested.
So the variable was how is going to get
my samples into a Wada lab and I start
talking to a scientist here by the name
of Don Catlin and Los Angeles and he's
considered the grandfather of
anti-doping.
He created all the tests for the first
test for steroid detection and sport.
And he actually,
uh,
is the first guy who did the testing for
the 1984 Olympics in Los Angeles,
which was the first time they ever did
anti-doping,
testing and sport.
So caitlin has developed all these tests
and,
and I get in touch with Catlin and he's
retired.
He's still alive,
I think he's about 80 years old and he
retired,
I don't know,
five,
six years ago.
And I quickly realized in talking to
Kaitlin that he's,
he's very frustrated.
He basically is,
felt that he spent his entire life and
career in a system that he was never
going to win at and that no matter what
he did and he would develop one
methodology to catch somebody the very
next day there'd be another way around
it.
And then he would develop another
methodology and then the very next day
there'd be someone around it or he would
propose that the league or the NFL or
baseball or wherever he wants say should
use this test to catch,
you know,
this sort of substance abuse and the
leagues would not use that test
intentionally or he would find positives
and report the positives and then be
told basically to,
you know,
pretend that there wasn't a positive
because his job was simply to report not
to police.
And he had spent an entire career with
this.
And um,
and so he has a,
you know,
I think a lot of frustrations with the
anti-doping system.
And he said that he wouldn't help me do
it because they,
he would've had to prescribe me drugs
and he didn't want to be liable for
that.
B,
he didn't know how he was going to get
my samples into a water lab because he
doesn't have access to that anymore.
And he was worried about his legacy.
He didn't want to,
as much as he felt all the fallacies and
the system,
he didn't want to be out there.
You know,
basically almost in a way,
making a mockery of,
of all of his work.
And he says,
Hey,
I know this scientists in Russia,
Gregory Rick Cheng cough,
he runs the water lab,
the World Anti Doping Agency lab for all
of Russia and I think he might help you
and you know,
essentially you said that because he
knew that the Russians had always been
kind of trying to,
to,
uh,
to figure out ways to game the system.
And uh,
and he had met Gregory,
uh,
in like 1983 and that's a whole other
story because Gregory had basically come
to the United States as a spy,
a to figure out what the Americans were
going to beat them against in the 1984
Olympics,
which I can talk about later.
But,
um,
uh,
I get in touch with gregory,
connects us through email and I start
emailing gregory and we spend about
eight months back and forth on emails,
calls.
At the time he had just done the Sochi
Olympics.
So he was doing all the testing for the
Sochi Olympics and he invites me out to
Oregon.
And this is July of 2014 to go meet him.
He's lecturing at this
symposium and he doesn't know at the
time that I want a dope.
He just thinks that I'm an American
filmmaker making a documentary,
exploring the anti-doping system in
sport.
So I go out to Oregon and I make a
decision that I'm not going to bring my
camera crews.
I'm not going to do anything other than
to just meet him.
Um,
and we start talking and I say to
Gregory and he had just finished the
Sochi Games.
I said,
do you believe that a medal in the
Olympics can be one without performance
enhancing drugs?
And he goes,
no.
And I say,
why?
And he says,
well,
I should believe I tried to believe,
but I don't believe a medal in the
Olympics can be one without performance
enhancing drugs.
And then he takes this pause,
I'll never forget this.
And he goes,
I don't know,
maybe I'm a bad man.
And he says to me.
And um,
and that was this moment where I went,
okay.
Clearly there is a,
a deeper story here that the,
the head of the anti-doping laboratory
in Russia's telling me that a,
he doesn't think you can win an Olympic
medal cleanly and be,
um,
he doesn't know whether or not he's a
bad man.
And um,
what was going through your head?
It was like a,
I think I just hit the motherload for,
for,
for uh,
what will be a riveting film and not
just Manhattan changes mobile story and,
and um,
and I say to him and we really bonded
and I really liked the guy,
like just,
just,
he's as you see in the film,
I mean he's impossible not to like,
you know,
and I liked him to.
I liken him Kinda like Bryan Cranston
and breaking bad.
I mean there's this guy who's living
this,
you know,
you love him and at the same time he's
doing things that he shouldn't be doing.
Um,
and he'd been living this double life
his entire life was living a double
life,
which is a,
which is insane.
And he agrees that he is going to help
me.
I'm dope and avoid detection.
But before this,
he agrees,
but he's not admitting to anything.
No,
not admitting to anything.
It's just showing you how it just says.
But he,
but he,
but he says,
look,
you know,
you're an amateur cyclist.
Um,
you're not a professional.
And in his mind,
even though I was quote unquote
cheating,
I wasn't cheating anyone out of
anything.
And you were doing it very openly.
Yeah.
And I was doing it very openly and,
and so he viewed it as kind of like,
hey,
this is,
this is a cool project to get involved
in.
And in his mind I think he also looked
at it as,
hey,
what's the big deal if I expose the
fallacies and the anti doping system
because maybe they'll actually do
something about it if I show a,
you know,
essentially how it doesn't work.
So he agrees that he's going to be my
doping advisor and this is now July
2014.
But I had to do the race clean first.
I then had to go and you know,
through this whole thing.
And I wasn't going to actually start
doping until essentially the beginning
of,
of the next year and beginning of 2015.
So you got to do the race clean to get a
base.
Yeah.
To do.
And because my whole premise was,
hey,
I'm going to do this race twice.
I'm gonna go in and do an clean,
see how good I do.
And then the next year I'm going to go
in just dope to the gills with the hope
that I'm going to win it.
Now.
How much cycling had you done before
this?
A lot.
I grew up racing when I was 13,
a race seriously ties 19.
But then I moved out to La at,
um,
I was in a huge,
like a horrific bike crash and as 19 and
a race and that essentially,
I guess,
um,
I didn't have the balls after that I
went back and race to not happen here,
uh,
last,
eight teeth.
All of these were shattered.
This one was knocked out entirely and
uh,
and it was like,
it was a bad wreck.
And um,
I was 19.
I just,
um,
my freshman year in college and some
went through college basically with
plastic teeth in my mouth as I was going
through essentially reconstructive
dental work,
um,
and it made me really think twice about
being a professional athlete or pursuing
cycling.
And I came back to it the following year
and as you know,
in any sort of competitive realm in
sport,
you can't be thinking about whether or
not you're going to get injured.
You can't be thinking about what those
risks are.
You have to be fully committed or you're
going to lose or you're going to get
dropped.
And,
and I found myself,
you know,
not following the,
we'll close enough.
I found myself holding back on
descendants.
I found myself like in my mind of Oh my
God,
what if this crash happens again?
And so I decided to stop racing and
moved out to la.
I got into the entertainment business is
doing standup comedy originally.
And um,
but cycling remained like my passion in
life.
So it's just like my life's therapy.
Like,
you know,
I'm stressed out,
I go on the bike and,
and so I've always rode.
But I stopped racing,
um,
but uh,
to go back and do this,
it was like,
okay,
it was a part of me where I'm going to
kind of go relive my,
my youth or the idea of how good I could
possibly be.
And um,
and the bigger element was it is.
I thought it was going to be a
compelling film and something that would
be very interesting not for cycling,
you know,
people that were into cycling but into
sports and curious about,
you know,
drug use in sport and performance
enhancing drugs and what they do and
what they don't do.
So the first run at it,
you had been off cycling for how long?
I had been a,
I had still been training and writing
and writing,
but the first ride out at,
I mean I like radically amped up my
training program for like six months
ahead of time because I was going to do
this thousand mile race through the
French Alps.
And in Europe the race called,
called the Haute route.
So you get ready for this now.
When you say clean,
are you taking any supplements?
Multivitamins,
do anything?
Let's say can vitamins has taken the
Korea team,
but I was always doing protein shakes.
I was doing,
um,
you know,
all sorts of recovery drinks and you
know,
essentially training,
uh,
you know,
getting my blood monitored and eating
super,
super healthy and you know,
essentially training is as you know,
as scientifically as I could,
um,
without using any sort of illegal
substances.
And so what kind of results did you get
the first race?
I got 14 out of 440 guys.
That's pretty damn good.
It was pretty good.
I was destroyed after it,
but it was pretty good.
So then the race is over.
How long after that do you start doping?
Um,
six months.
So you wait six months.
Six months.
I wait six months.
Are you training at all during the
interview?
Just really.
I'm training,
but I'm filming,
I'm filming interviews because I was
filming,
I probably had 50,
60 interviews that never made it into
the film because the film took this
pivot.
Have you thought about releasing those
in some way or something like that?
You know,
I've thought about,
you know,
it's,
it's Netflix technically would have the
rights to that are,
you know,
at least the first right to it.
Um,
so,
you know,
perhaps I would do like a,
a side series.
I'm behind decorous right.
Could you roll out all these various
interviews because I interviewed so many
interesting people.
Yeah.
Because I was so compelled by the end of
it.
Uh,
you know,
it could have been a series,
I could have,
you could have kept going with it.
Um,
so six months after then you,
you get back together with Gregory.
Yeah.
And so I get that exactly.
So I get back to Greg Gregory and in the
film you see this skype call and um,
so in a creative filmmaking process,
editorially,
you're always faced with decisions of,
okay,
do I spend 10 minutes of this film on
all these emails back and forth to
Gregory before we see him on skype?
Well,
that's not as dynamic is,
boom,
you see I'm on skype.
So,
so,
uh,
that very first call,
which was the very first time I had had
him on skype and,
and it was the first time that I'd seen
him since Oregon in July,
2014 and now on beginning
my protocol and there he is shirtless
and willing to help me.
And at almost that very moment,
this German television,
a show comes out like a 60 minutes
piece.
I'm called a ard as the station.
And this German investigative reporter
Hio separate who unbenounced to me at
the time.
It had been following the story of
essentially the possibility of Russia
having a state sponsored doping program
had already interviewed Gregory.
And he puts together this like 30 minute
explosive,
like 60 minutes show alleging that
Russia has a state sponsored doping
program and that he's working with these
two whistleblowers that basically fled
Russia to go work with him in Germany
and tell their story.
And these two whistleblowers and now
like enemies of the state.
And they're worried about their lives
and there's threats to their lives.
And they essentially start bringing
forward information about a state
sponsor program.
And the information is so compelling
that water,
the world antidoping agency launches and
investigation into the claims behind
this German television show and there's
a backstory to that,
which is the water had had this
information for four years and they sat
on it because they're essentially embed
with the IOC and the Olympics.
So the only reason why they finally
acted on this information out of Russia
was they were forced to because it was
now in public and this German show had
done kind of the equivalent of putting
it on the front page of a New York
Times.
And so they had to take action.
So water launches this investigation,
it's now January 2015 and I'm just
working with Gregory and Gregory shows
me,
he says,
Hey,
have you seen this television show on
me?
And at the time I hadn't.
And I've watched this show.
And there it is.
Areas being alleged as essentially the
guy who was doping all the Russian
athletes that he knows everything.
There's athletes on camera saying that
Dr [inaudible] is the guy you go to.
And,
uh,
and it was a major pivot point in the
story,
but for me at the time,
I made a very,
very,
uh,
succinct decision which was I'm going to
continue behind the scenes to follow
this story,
this investigation,
because I didn't know where it was going
to go,
but in the meantime,
I have gregory,
this Moscow scientist,
he's helping me to avoid detection and
that's the movie that I set out to me.
And so I'm going to stick on that
journey wall wall,
doubling down on the other side of the
story should this side of the story
ended up truly being something.
And so this is essentially a year.
And so he's doping me this entire year
while he's under investigation wall.
I'm literally going to guys like Dick
Pound,
who,
who founded water and Richard Mclaren,
who's investigating him and,
and the guys within water and different
guys in,
in global anti-doping.
And I'm saying,
Hey,
um,
what do you know about this Russia
investigation?
What do you think of this proves true?
Why do you think Gregory [inaudible]
involved?
And um,
and none of these people that I'm
interviewing know that I'm working with
Gregory,
they have no idea that I'm doping.
They have no idea that I know Gregory
and so I'm getting these very,
very candid,
honest responses and,
and we cut to November 2015,
um,
and this 335 page report breaks and it's
alleging that he's the mastermind of the
state sponsored doping program in
Russia,
but again,
it's all smoke and mirrors and it's
mandated to track and field.
And uh,
and that's when things got incredibly
serious.
Putin gets on state television.
It's a huge worldwide story.
Denies that any of this is true,
but he makes a statement stating that if
any of this is true,
that it will be the individuals that are
held accountable and that punishment
will be absolute.
And that was essentially Gregory's death
sentence.
And we were skyping and we were talking
during this entire period as this crisis
is unfolding in Russia and he's forced
to resign from the lab.
The lab is shut down.
Everybody's let go.
Russia is suspended from world track and
field.
Gregory tells me that the KGB,
the FSB,
have plotted a suicide,
uh,
a plan to make it look like he's,
that he's killed himself and that he
needs to get out of Russia.
And how did he know that they had
planned that?
So Gregory had,
um,
FSB clearance because he was essentially
fsp,
he was part of a secret operation by
Russia to essentially dope all of its
athletes,
have them avoid detection,
swap urine,
etc.
And so gregory was,
you know,
had high clearance and other people
within the fsb that liked him basically
said,
hey,
you got to get out.
And um,
so,
uh,
I got him a plane ticket.
I put them,
I put it on my credit card and he
arrives in los angeles.
This is November,
2015 years,
let him fly.
So this,
I am sure a to putin and the russian
ministry officials.
This has probably been the,
uh,
behind closed doors screaming,
shouting matches.
I'm going to cut your head off.
How did you allow this to happen?
Conversation.
But he gets out of Russia five days
after this,
uh,
335 page report breaks.
And he had been working with the
ministry,
so a,
they didn't consider him a flight with
b,
he was still going to the lab every day
to clean up the mess and see he had a
visa to come to the United States to
lecture,
but they weren't thinking that he had a
visa at that moment.
They weren't viewing him as a flight
risk even though they put to fsb agents
living in his home to guard him.
Um,
and it was,
and it was a blip,
was a blip.
They hadn't tagged.
his passport had happened so fast.
He had this visa and he,
and you bought the ticket.
So they didn't.
They knew.
They didn't know that he had a ticket
probably.
That's right.
Wow.
And he gets out and he gets out.
And I'm sure that,
I mean,
there's
probably been endless,
uh,
you know,
people getting their,
jobs lost in Russia because this guy was
able to get out at the least.
Yeah.
now,
uh,
and that's at the least is a very
important point because at least one guy
wound up dead to,
to what,
what,
and what was the circumstances like very
suspicious circumstances,
right.
So,
uh,
so gregory arrives to a los angeles and
he brings with him a three hard drives
and on these hard drives essentially is
the irrefutable evidence of essentially
russia's state sponsored doping program.
And this system,
um,
when I began to truly understand what
this was,
I mean this upends all of world sport,
this changes whether the olympics want
to acknowledge it or not.
This changes all oF olympic hiStory.
It changes the last 40 years of the
olympics Because it basically shows that
pretty much every metal ever won by
Russia in olympic competition was,
was,
was one through a illicit means that
gregory was behind a state sponsored
doping program where essentially pretty
much every athlete on the russian
national team was a,
you know,
an employee of the russian state and
that Russia had,
um,
you know,
went into each one of these olympic
games and world competition cheating,
uh,
to use sport as a way to assert itself
geopolitically and as a way to,
to show itself as a strong country.
And we forget.
Um,
I think in the us,
I mean a,
I mean a sport is what people care about
on this planet.
But you know,
orwell said it best at sport is war
without the weapons.
And if you look at what these olympic
games are every two years,
it's,
it's every country on planet earth
coming together under the illusion of
peace and goodwill and harmony.
While the governments are looking at
this as a way to assert geo political
power and strength.
So if you're China coming into the
olympics like they did in those beijing
olympics and they swept those beijing
olympics and from the information that I
have,
the essentially did the same thing that
Russia did in the sochi olympics.
But if you're looking,
let's say at China in those 20 2008
beijing games,
they spend billions of dollars.
the world has never seen an olympic
games like those beijing games,
the opening ceremonies and closing
ceremonies.
What that was was that was China showing
the world war first world power.
We can kick your ass.
We are have nukes.
We are a global economic force and look
what we can do world because the entire
world's eyes are on the olympics being
watched by billions of people.
You think thAt china's a great country.
Look what we're able to do.
And on top of that they needed to win
because it's not enough just to show
this infrastructure they can build.
It's also we can,
when we are superior,
and that is what countries have been
doing for the last 40 years in the
olympic games,
just like hitler did in the 1936 games
that helped unify his power and help,
you know,
bring Germany together.
And so this is what the history of the
olympic games have been shrouding under
this mask of peace and goodwill and
unity and handshakes.
This is countries around the world going
in and showing the rest of the world
their strength and power and Russia,
uh,
certaInly has viewed that,
every two years as a platform for Russia
to assert itself geopolitically.
And,
and in so doing,
they put together a state sponsored
doping program to help you know,
a advance russia's geopolitical goals
and,
and show itself as a world power.
Is there any evidence that china's done
the same thing or it's just a
speculation that they've got a state
sponsored program as well?
Well,
uh,
I personally don't have the evidence
according to gregory and I have no
reason to doubt gregory,
uh,
especially in light of everything that
he has said has proven to be true.
Uh,
he was at the 2008 patient games and
according to him,
what would happen different than what
Russia did in sochi,
but according to him,
what would happen is that the chinese
athletes,
and if you look at the metal count out
of beijing,
China swept,
swept those olympics just like Russia
swept their own olympics.
Um,
and,
uh,
accordIng to gregory,
what the russian,
uh,
what the chinese athletes would do is
they would show up for their,
you know,
their doping test and certain
collectors,
meaning when the athlete shows up,
they have to be chaperoned and they're
basically chaperoned.
Nat chaperone,
watches them pee into,
you know,
a contaIner.
And then they put the p in these two
different bottles.
And this is the whole safeguard system.
According to gregory,
what was happening in China is that the,
the collectors were actually chinese
government agents essentially like
secret service for China.
And that the athlete would go in to have
his urine collected and this agent would
give the athlete a bag of,
of his clean urine,
and the athlete would put that urine
under his armpit and then collect,
collect the urine.
and,
uh,
and that's apparently what China did in
the beijing olympics according to
gregory and he had knowledge of a hat
and that is where the idea started to
come,
uh,
for how to put into place what they
ultimately did in sochi,
um,
where they swapped out clean urine for
dirty urine.
But they did it in a much more
complicated matter because of the camera
systems,
because of all the technology that was
in place.
Um,
Russia took it to a whole other step
further.
Those lids that they had used,
those supposedly unbreakable lids or
anon removable lids.
Yes.
Um,
had they been in pLace before sochi?
Yes.
So,
um,
uh,
whAt,
what we're talking about is in the um,
in when an athlete reports for a drug
test in sport,
um,
they pinned a one like,
like,
uh,
you know,
a,
uh,
a cup and then they separate their urine
between an,
a sample and a b sample.
And These two bottles are made by the
swiss company called berlinger and they
are kind of the fort knox of urine
collection bottles.
They've created this tamper proof top.
It seals like it's a vault aNd this has
been considered the global standard.
There it is right there we can see on
the screen and these are considered the,
the,
the global standard in world sport and
they're unpenetrable.
And if you see here on these,
on these bottles,
the a be a sample is allowed to be
opened by the lab,
right?
So they have the machine,
it's this special machine and it cracks
the top and then you can test it.
The beast sample is sealed forever.
It's only to be opened
if the,
a sample turns positive and that b
sample was put into longterm storage for
10 years.
Basically should testing evolve or
whatever or something come up,
they have this b sample to go back and
test that athlete urine of up to 10
years in the olympic vault in the
olympic,
you know,
uh,
labs where they've whole holding these
samples.
So basically what Russia figured out is
that they needed to swap out both the,
a urine and the urine,
but in order to get into those be
samples,
they had to break into these bottles.
So through a couple of years of testing
and the fsb got involved in a program
where they figured out using these
tools,
how to essentially break into these
bottles undetected,
dump out the dirty,
dirty piss,
put in clean piss and reseal these
bottles.
So both the,
a sample would be negative because that
was swapped and the beast sample had
been swapped and it was in longterm
storage.
So be a sample because if so if they
removed the top of the bc and they swap
that out,
what do they do with the sample while
the a sample they.
They were,
they were legally able to open it for
teSting but it was supposed to be tested
under,
you know,
a bunch of other people watching.
so what they would do,
and thIs gets into,
into detail into the film,
is that they would take basically the,
a sample that was already in this room.
They'd smuggle in the samPle.
The sample shouldn't even been there and
they would crack open the a sample,
like they were allowed to crack open for
testing but they would do this at like
2:00
in the morning and they would bRing this
a sample and the sample through a secret
hole in the wall of the room.
Were there or were they were allocating
the urine.
There's,
there's the holes in the wall and they
would pass these bottles through the
hole in the wall.
And once they got through the hole in
the wall on the other side,
in this makeshift room,
which was a looked like a storage
closet,
but there were no cameras in there and
they had designed the whole lab for
this.
I mean this was,
there was a lot of thinking that went
into this blueprint.
I mean,
gregory showed me the blueprints.
I mean this was,
this was thought out years ahead of time
how to do this.
And they would swap.
They'd bring the bottles into the
storage room.
They would dump out the dirty urine of
the a sample because that was open.
They would put in the clean urine at
that same athlete that they had
collected about a year earlier.
They would.
They took all the athletes off the drug
and what had them collect clean samples.
And Then the b bottle would go out a
secretly to a kgb building,
an fsb building that was about 100 yards
across the street from where the lab
was,
a secret building.
And there they would open up this b
sample.
They would dump out the urine,
bring it back to gregory sitting in this
room.
Gregory would then put that same clean
urine into that be bottle,
reseal the be bottle,
put the tuba holes through the hole in
the lab.
They then take the sample,
smuggle it into,
uh,
into where it was supposed to be,
the longterm storage container and all
the athletes says it negative.
Wow.
Now what do they do in the past?
If they did that in sochi,
what did they do in beijing?
What do they do in all the previous
olympics also?
That's where it,
it's uh,
it's interesting because,
and this is kinda the,
the lance armstrong of it,
or you want to call a v anti-doping
system,
evasion of it.
Where in the past it was always about
the science,
right?
Which is,
okay,
what can you take?
What can you not take?
How long will you wash out?
How long were you,
you know,
what can you know?
And,
and at what time would you be positive
and negative?
And that goes into the weeds.
Like,
you know,
hgh is hard to detect after 12 hours if
you take micro doses of epo,
there's all these,
you know,
different ways around it.
And they were essentially doing that,
but they were doing it on a higher
level.
I'm gregory and this is just again,
the incredible to lives that he was
leading his.
So he's the head of the anti-doping lab
in Russia.
So he's responsible for testing all of
russian athletes and international
athletes coming into Russia,
uh,
for competition at the same time he is
developing test to catch these athletes
and he develops a test called the
longterm metabolite test.
And what this test does is it increases
the detection window to detect steroids
in the blood of athletes.
So prior they could essentially detect
steroids,
use a about,
it was about a six week window,
something about that,
right.
If,
once you hadn't been taken steroids for
about six weeks,
you weren't going to test positive.
He develops this test that is able to
detect steroid use up to like seven or
eight months in the system.
and this is different types of steroids.
correct?
Because some steroids have a long life
inside the body,
they're fat soluble.
Exactly.
So he's able to determIne a to,
to develop a test that the longterm
metabolites that to basically see that
you took these drugs,
you know,
even if you hadn't taken them for six
months,
but at the same time that he develops
this test and this has now been adopted
on a global level and specifically at
the,
like the london olympics of 2012.
Um,
and,
and I think,
don't quote me on this.
I think this test really got approved in
like 2011,
somewhere around there.
And so he puts out this longterm
metabolite tests that's catching all
these athletes from all over the world
because now they can catch them up to
six,
seven months.
He figures out the antivenom to his own
tests and what he develops as a three
drug cocktail where he is able to
dissolve the steroids in,
in a solution of either vermouth,
martini for the women,
for the men,
whiskey for the men.
And He would give the athletes basically
the steroids in like a shot in the
solution of alcohol.
And what he figured out through the
sciences that if the steroids were
taking with alcohol,
they wouldn't actually go into the blood
system.
So you would get all the benefits of the
steroid,
but your body would pass it out.
And I'm very,
very quick time.
And so you were undetectable.
Wow.
Yeah.
How did he figure that out?
Because he's a genius.
So.
Wow.
So,
so,
so this guy is,
you know,
essentially,
at one time,
you know,
so he's figuring out.
So all the russian athletes are
basically knowing,
you know,
they're on his system.
And so there's taken steroids while the
other athletes,
if they were doing the same thing on a
global level or getting caught.
And the world system is using the
methodology the gregory developed.
Wow.
Uh,
and so,
so this was the cat and mouse game going
on for very long time.
And,
and you know,
before that it's,
you know,
it's the microdosing,
it's the lance of it,
it's all the,
the,
how do you,
how do you get away with it?
Um,
but what they did for sochi is they just
said,
well,
hey,
screw that,
you know,
we don't want to take any chances.
We're going to have our athlete dope,
full tilt so they can be at their very,
very best and they're going to be dirty
as hell,
but we're going to swap out their urine.
So there's no,
because in sochi,
Russia controlled the lab,
they basically own the keys to the
vault.
They were the policemen,
they,
they were the judge,
the jury and the executioner.
They had full control and they had a
record number of goals,
right?
They had a reCord number that they won
13 goals in sochi,
33 overall metals,
which was the highest of any country.
And,
and for him,
for putin and Russia.
Um,
I think when you go into,
you know,
what's going on in the us and Russia is,
there's the,
the cold war is never really ended.
It's the illusion of a cold war ending.
And what you're seeing is,
is,
you know,
a country where economically,
um,
it's always Been,
you know,
you have a lot of wealth in a very,
very small number of hands,
but the rest of the country is pretty
much living in second world conditions,
you know,
once you get out of moscow and st
peteRsburg and where the,
where the main money is.
But rush on a global level is always
wanting to assert itself as a,
you know,
as a world geo political power.
They have nukes,
they have a lot of,
you know,
uh,
resources,
resources.
And in the case of,
of sochi,
this was a way for essentially putin to
show like China did on a global level.
Look what we're able to pull off in
these olympics.
They spent $50,
billion dollars on those olympics.
Nobody had ever done that.
His approval rating had been on the
decline.
But if he could win the olympics,
he could unify Russia just like Germany
winning the world cup or any,
you know,
this is because this is what sports is
on a global level,
or you know,
the denver broncos winning the
superbowl.
The patriots winning the super bowl and
every single person in new england shows
up for a parade,
people care,
and so the olympics were putin's way to
basically show the world that Russia was
an economic power,
superpower,
geopolitical power.
And if those russian athletes could win,
that's the same thing of going to war.
That showing that,
that they are,
you know,
that Russia is strong.
And so the mandate was win at all costs.
Gregory was the mastermind behind that
program and right after they win those
sochi olympics,
putin's approval rating sores to 95
percent and he uses that approval rating
to go into the Ukraine and to,
uh,
and to go into war with Ukraine.
I'd never connected those together until
your documentary,
when you were talking about them
invading crimea instantaneously made me
reconsider the,
the impact of sports like geo
politically.
Like I really didn't think about it that
way before that movie and a after the
movie was what stuck with me the most.
And one of the most disturbing things is
I remember the news where they were
talking about kicking them out of Brazil
where they were saying that the
international olympic committee was
going to remove all the russian athletes
from competing in Brazil.
And I saw the story and I think we
probably even talked about it on the
podcast.
I was like,
this is insane.
Like I'd never.
This is unprecedented.
And then
it went away.
Then it went away.
And,
and what you see in the film and what's
going on right now,
which is so upsetting in the state of
the world that we're in right now is his
first is in the film from this
investigation that gets launched from a
gregory,
uh,
going to the New York times and us
presenting all this evidence.
They launched this a three months
investigation.
And,
um,
I'm essentially behind the scenes kind
of as a puppet master because gregory
can't talk.
He's in protective custody.
And so I'm the guy with his lawyers
helping facilitate all the evidence,
helping to decipher all the documents.
And we had hired on a whole team of
people to do this.
And that's that scene in the movie where
you see where I'm sitting at the table,
but the leaders of water basically,
you know,
telling them that the easter bunny and
claus and the tooth
fairy don't exist all at the same time.
And uh,
and,
and so this investigation goes on for
two and a half months.
And during this investigation,
richard mclaren gets the samples,
the sochi samples out of the longterm
storage from the olympics,
the ioc and luzon.
They do forensics on these bottles and
they see the scratches on the bottles.
They see how the bottles were open,
they bring in,
um,
interpol and other agencies and they
figure out the tools,
how Russia gets into the bottles and
they see all the evidence on the
bottles.
And then they also find,
um,
an,
uh,
an extraordinary amount of salt content
in the urine because what gregory was
doing,
which we don't get into the film,
is in order to make the clean urine
match,
he also had to adjust the gravity of the
urine.
And he would use human table salt to do
that.
And so when they went back and they have
the,
yeah,
when you,
when you pee,
depending on how hydrated you are,
dehydrated you are what you ate that
day.
The gravity,
essentially the weight of your urine
changes.
Basically what the content of what,
what's what,
what your body is dehydrated.
People have dark urine,
exact.
Is that a thicker urine?
Is that what exactly?
It's like a heavier urine,
right?
So,
so every athlete,
when they would give their sample part
of the doping control forms,
they mark the specific gravity.
Essentially the weight,
the biologic of the airport.
Is it a part of it?
A different.
Because the biological passport is
blood,
uh,
that's.
And that's measuring blood,
but so,
so they're just measuring the weight of
the urine.
Well,
they're,
they're measuring part of when they do
the intake form on the urine,
they way,
oh,
I see a eloquent.
And so that.
So that it's also another thing against
fraud because okay,
so your specific gravity as I'm making
this up point o two o.
And that's in that sample will.
So if they were to go back and retest
that sample and the specific gravity was
wrong,
will they know that something was
something was up.
So part of swapping the uranus,
he would also adjust the specific
gravity with table salt.
He figured out that salt salt would
would change the gravity of urine.
So because he's trying to match on the
doping control forms.
exactly.
You know what's in these bottles,
he puts in table salt and when they go
back and test these samples,
sure enough,
in 100 percent of the samples they test,
they find evidence of the scratches,
they find evidence of tampering and they
find the table salt in the urine.
So this is,
this is like,
I mean this is beyond a reasonable doubt
that this system,
this is a slam dunk and it's now the rio
olympic games and we're sitting there
and going,
well,
every country in the world is calling
for Russia to be band.
Every antidoping agency around the world
is calling for Russia to be band.
Every op-ed and New York times and paper
from around the world is saying you have
to ban Russia from rio and thomas bach,
the president of the olympics,
essentially a has the aUdacity to call
these findings and all this evidence,
um,
uh,
allegationS and does not banned Russia
from the rio olympics,
allows them in so 281,
I think number 390 athletes go to rio
and the only athletes that are banned or
the world track and field team because
he kicked the buck down to the sports
federations to decide what to do.
And because this investigation had
started in track and field track and
field and sebastian coe upheld the ban
for the rio games.
And here we are now a year and a couple
months later and now the olympics are
trying to decide whether or not to allow
Russia into the next winter olympic
games.
And not only have they essentially
removed richard mclaren from this
investigation.
And he was able to continue the work
through december.
And in december of,
um,
of last year,
2016,
he is able to release his full findings.
And these full findings have 1200
documents of evidence of emails between
gregory and the ministry emails between,
uh,
you know,
on and on that had been forensically
proven using medidata where these emails
were coming from,
the spreadsheets of what every single
athlete was taking when they were taking
it.
The bottle collection numbers,
I mean,
you're talking because I've seen the
evidence,
I mean,
it is,
it's a graveyard,
it's mind boggling.
And richard mclaren concludes that over
1000 athletes across all sports were
involved in this state sponsored doping
operation and the olympics until a
couple weeks ago,
uh,
had done essentially nothing,
with this information they have only
trying to figure out essentially how to
push it under the carpet and pretend
that this didn't happen.
How to allow Russia into the next winter
olympics by finding loopholes.
By saying that you can't,
uh,
you know,
that,
that it should be the individual
athletes,
right,
etc.
Etc.
and they have an investigation going on
right now,
uh,
which is the investigation to
investigate richard mclaren's
investigation,
which was already forensically proven.
Everything was already shown bond a
reasonable doubt.
But to essentially figure out,
um,
whether or not they are going to allow
Russia into the winter olympics,
um,
and they are finally reaching out to
gregory even though he has been
available,
uh,
for a year and three months to speak to
them.
They are finally reaching out to him,
uh,
to have him provide the same evidence
that he provided to richard mclaren,
uh,
and the investigators on that team.
So they're very reluctantly pursuing
this or very reluctantly even
contemplating banning Russia.
I think what we're seeing is we're
seeing,
um,
you know,
I,
I set out making a movie,
exploring the anti-doping system and
sport and,
and I uncovered essentially the biggest
scandal in sport history,
but behind that scandal is I'm seeing
essentially the geopolitics and the
business interests of all these
organizations that basically stand for
one thing.
They say that they're for something and
that they're doing everything to protect
their own business interests and do the
exact opposite of what they say that
they stand for.
And it calls into question that if the
olympics are up there going,
play clean,
be true,
be fair,
don't do this.
Play by the rules,
come into this,
to these competitions,
uh,
you know,
and,
and respect fellow athletes and then
they're presented with a scandal on epic
proportions,
a scandal that changes its entire
history that has been forensically
proven beyond a reasonable doubt.
And then they don't uphold their own
rules and they don't act or have a
punishment for this.
I mean,
you have to ask what's the point of the
olympics?
Why even had the olympics?
What,
why,
why should any athlete on planet earth
who is competing cleanly,
who's training their whole lives to go
into these games with the belief that
they are on at least a level playing
field,
uh,
theoretically.
Um,
and then you have the organization
itself not protecting the rights of
clean athletes.
You have to call into question why,
why,
why have the olympics?
Why?
What's,
what's the point of it if,
if this kind of behavior is allowed and
it's,
and it's an punishable,
what do you think is going on?
I think that you have billions and
billions and billions of dollars at
stake.
Um,
you know,
look,
I mean Russia is hosting the world cup
this summer,
uh,
vitaly mutko who was the sports minister
who was elevated to essentially the vice
president oF ruSsia,
the,
the deputy prime minister after this
doping scandal to Basically because
putin took him out of harm's way.
Um,
you know,
he was sitting on the board of fifa.
He helped Russia get the world cup bid,
you know,
so that they were hosting the world cup
next year.
This is billions of dollars,
you know,
a pollutant and bach are known to be
very good friends.
I mean,
back and the olympics,
you know,
brought in billions and billions of
dollars from Russia hosting those sochi
games.
You know,
this is,
this is business.
There is no,
there is no interest in essentially
just,
you know,
knocking over the apple cart in the
protection of a fair sport or athletes,
right or fair play.
And you know,
and the athletes that are essentially
the victim of,
of a countries geopolitical interests
and business interests.
And,
and I mean we see this across all
sports,
but this is a case where it's night and
day and,
and you're literally sitting at,
at,
at evidence that is so staggering in its
scope and scale and an organization that
is basically like unable to,
to act in any sort of ethical or moral
capacity to implement any sort of
justice against what has been thousands
and thousands and thousands of athletes
stolen.
ThoUsands and thousands and thousands of
metals stolen from clean athletes all
over the world.
Not just american athletes,
but I mean any athlete and went into
those games a clean and a rush and beat
them.
They basically got their metal stolen
from them.
Are they hoping that this is just going
to be swept under the rug and that
there's going to be more news that sort
of drowns us out
in my personal opinion.
That's how I see it.
Um,
you know,
I'm gregory a rut jancov.
He wrote a op-ed to the New York times.
It was published last week and the head,
um,
his attorneys,
because he's in protective custody,
we're able to facilitate this op-ed to
the New York times and in the op ed,
if you read it,
he goes into detail about the evidence
that he's provided a,
the ios sees lack of interest in doing
anything and essentially,
you know,
his opinion on russia's cover up.
and here we are.
I'm not once has Russia accepted any
responsibility for this.
Um,
in fact,
they've denied that this ever happened.
They're continuing to blame gregory,
that this is like a solo act.
How could this man have pulled off this
system,
this huge elaborate system,
uh,
by himself.
And then in so doing,
after the New York times op ed Russia
issues
an arrest warrant for gregory,
uh,
and there's already been criminal
charges against him in Russia.
they've seized all of his property and
assets in Russia.
They've taken a,
in the process of taking a,
a,
a home that he bought for his daughter.
They're trying to take his wife's
property.
They took his dacha and this is all a
man who was working for the russian
ministry who had the backbone to become
a whistleblower and we're still in this
cycle of fake news and denial and I,
and I'm witnessing this on a,
on a daily basis and it's a,
and it's unbelievable because when you
look at this story and then you draw a
line which is so easy to draw onto the
current us political climate and what is
going on with russian meddling in our
election.
You go,
well,
if Russia was willing to do tHis for the
last 40 years and we have all the
evidence now that they actually did this
and they have denied it and continue to
deny it and don't take any
responsibility.
and not only that,
anybody who is who is spoke out against
them ends up dead or you know,
or they end up in jail or they end up,
you know,
in a fake news cycle.
I think it's pretty.
You know,
I,
I think there can be a straighten
analogy into,
you know,
if there's any question as to whether or
not,
uh,
our,
our election was meddled with or whether
or not Russia is able to,
uh,
to assert its power geo politically.
I think this film answers that question
and then I'm hoping that,
that,
that our country is gonna wake up and
go,
hey,
we're not going to tolerate this.
This is not acceptable.
We're not going to allow a foreign power
to metal into,
uh,
into our election process or into the
potential leadership of this country.
I mean,
it's,
uH,
it's pretty,
it's pretty scary when you think of the
bigger implications of,
of what this scandal is an was on a
global level.
And then looking at what that means,
you know,
even for America.
Well,
it's essentially highlighting the
intentions and what the russians are
willing to do a in sport that the
evidence though of doping is so far and
beyond the evidence that we have so far
about election tampering.
Right?
We have evidence of election tampering.
But what you're telling me is just so
ridiculously undeniable.
And what your documentary shows is so
ridiculously undeniable,
it's just stunning that they're allowing
the russians to compete.
I mean,
it's,
it's really scary when you really think
about it that way.
Meaning like what is,
are they being threatened?
I mean,
what is it just a simply a money thing
as you're saying?
I mean when we're talking about
thousands and thousands of athletes and
over who knows?
I mean there was recently a couple of
russian wrestlers had their metals taken
away after the fact because they had new
detection methods,
I believe it was from,
I want to say 2008 or 2012.
Yeah,
right.
Yeah.
They're finding a lot of positives in
2012,
2008.
It's been a little bit harder because of
statute of limitations on the retesting
of samples and for,
for a lot of reasons,
the ioc doesn't really want to go in
there and get all those samples to
retest and what there's been so much
that it proves that the olympics are a
fraud,
but there's been so much in the past.
There's been so many,
so many allegations of deception and
fraud.
When it came to the olympics in the
first place,
there's always been some brewing behind
the scenes,
but you must have been stunned in the
process of making this documentary about
one thing.
And then while thiS is happening,
you know,
just completely,
I mean,
it seems like synchronicity or something
like you just tapped into it at the very
moment that this,
this dream was becoming a raging river
public.
Really.
It was a weird moment because I,
uh,
like I,
I like Russia,
I love russian,
have tons of Russia to Russia.
I've really day guys.
I really do.
I mean,
you know,
it's god.
I mean,
I,
I jusT did.
It's for anybody who's been to Russia.
I mean,
it's,
it's pretty awesome.
I mean,
moscow and st petersburg or world class
cities have so many russian friends,
so,
you know,
so we're,
we're caught back up into these cold war
politics where essentially all of us
individuals,
you know,
on an individual level,
go,
hey,
I,
I love Russia,
I love russian site.
And russians go,
I love americans.
And yeT we're caught up into the
geopolitics like we were in the cold war
between our leaders and the government
workings and the ministry that we have
nothing to do with it.
And,
and what was shocking to me is,
you know,
I think over the last 20 years we've
viewed Russia as our friend,
that they're,
you know,
that there are friend.
And what we're learning now is that it's
been a,
it's been a pretend pat on the back
while we're seeing the government,
um,
uh,
do things and we're learning things of,
of russian tampering and involvement,
um,
that I think that americans,
a year or two ago,
couldn't,
couldn't have imagined.
And,
and the fact that this story that I
uncovered then collides with the
election meddling and hacking
and,
and a russian involvement into Syria,
etc.
Etc.
Um,
and that,
those things were all coming together at
the same time.
I'm in a,
I couldn't have imagined because even as
I uncovered this scandal and worked to
expose us,
uh,
and bring it forward,
um,
I had no idea at the time,
that there would be,
um,
claims of that,
uh,
that our election was hacked.
That was never even a discussion before
this cycle.
That was never even a discussion.
I can imagine that
now when,
when you,
when this all came out and you put this
all together,
I mean you had to think to yourself
like,
what I've just made is going to change
sports is what I think your documentary
is the most powerful anti-doping
documentary ever made.
I really do.
And I Think what you've done
fortuitously,
for you to be involved in this and be
involved with gregory as this was all
going down.
I mean,
it's really crazy how the two coincided
together and produced this staggering
result.
When you're sitting there at the table
with all these water guys and you're
discussing everything,
it's almost like they didn't want to
hear it.
It's Almost,
it's almost like what you were doing was
exposing incompetence and corruption and
indefensible way.
That's right,
that's right.
They,
um,
they didn't want to hear it because it
basically showed that their system had
been utterly ineffective at catching
cheaters.
It showed that,
that,
that they,
it caught them with their pants down.
And um,
and as I got into the weeds on this,
you know,
you realize that that water essentially
as co funded by the olympics have 50
percent of waters budget is through the
olympics.
So they're,
they're in bed together.
They Are,
they don't want to do anythIng that's
going to hurt the other.
You also realize that there are um,
many board members have water or part of
the ioc.
So like craig reedy who is the president
of water,
is also the vice president of the ioc.
Dick pound who founded water was running
for the presidency of the ioc and was a
vice president of the ioc.
So,
so the olympIcs and water or totally
interconnected to each other.
And,
and in my opinion,
or at least what what grigory has told
me,
is that water was essentially
established as an arm of the ioc to help
protect a sponsorship dollar and to end
to make the olympics appear as clean as
you as up to their
olympic ideals.
So you know what you're seeing it within
these organizations is,
is water has no power to actually do
anything.
So all that they can do is observe and
report.
So in the case of,
of this,
the scandal gets uncovered.
They then do an investigation,
they corroborate everything as truth,
and then they advise the olympics water,
bless their heart,
advise the olympics,
that they should be banned Russia from
the summer games in rio,
and that they should ban Russia from the
winter games coming up and launching
water that was waters recommendation to
which the olympics did not take that
recommendation.
And water doesn't have any power to
actually enforce punishment.
So in case of,
in the case of Russia and talking to
people inside of water that we're
dealing with this over those four years
as they're getting all this information
from Russia.
but ultimately what is going,
we don't have the budget,
we don't really have the money to do
this.
They have like a $25,
million dollar a year global budget for
the entire world.
So we don't have the budget to do this.
We don't have the manpower to do this.
And ultimately we don't have the power
to do anything anyway.
Um,
and how are we going to go take on
Russia?
So they sat on the information realizing
that they were ultimately going to be
powerless to do anything.
So,
you know,
it's a,
it's a very complicated system because,
you know,
at least from what I've seen is there's
so much politics and geopolitics around
it,
uh,
that,
that keeps these operations essentially,
um,
you know,
ineffective and actually really doing
something and the anti-doping sport and
in a almost becomes an ethical and moral
decision.
Uh,
if the organizations and leaders
themselves are not really trying to do
anything about it.
Wow.
Now do you think the banning of the
track and field team was just a slap on
the wrist or was that a compromise that
was reached where they decided,
look,
we have to do something with,
what should we do?
Well,
what had happened is,
is um,
so the first report was all track and
field mandated and,
and there was so much evidence in
regards to track and field more than
other sport,
more than other sports because there was
an individual investigation that only
focused on track and field.
And even after they released this
investigation,
all of these athletes are saying,
well,
wait,
you got to go investigate biathlon.
You couldn't go investigate bobsled.
You kind of go investigate speed skating
and wrestling and wrestling and soccer
and basketball and everything.
But,
but they didn't do that.
And um,
so there was so much in,
in the track and field investigation,
the athletics investigation that the
iwf,
the international
athletics federation dealing with her
own scandal.
If you remember this a few years ago,
the head of the iwf was arrested on
bribery and lou lamonte dsac and his
son.
I'm,
it's a whole thing.
And sebastian coe became president and
there was all this proof that the I was,
had been taking bribes for years and
years and years to cover up positive
results.
And it's,
that's a whole other story.
Yeah.
So the,
so the iwf upholds the ban and they
uphold the ban,
um,
because of gregory's evidence.
So they were trying to figure out
whether or not to uphold the band and it
was on the eve of the rio olympics and a
gregory through the authorities that he
was been working with,
uh,
was able to get that evidence and
information to the iwf.
The iwf was able to see that and they
upheld the ban for russia's track and
field team,
which you know,
is a,
is a pretty,
pretty big,
um,
you know,
punishment.
At least it's at least it's taking a
stance of,
um,
you know,
this kind of behavior is not going to be
tolerated.
Some,
some.
Yeah.
Now,
gregory,
what are courageous and bold move on his
part and what a sacrifice to come forth
with all this evidence to risk his life
and to.
I mean,
essentially blow the lid off all of
this.
I mean,
if it wasn't for him,
what would you have?
Nothing.
You know?
Um,
it's been,
uh,
you know,
I worry about him every day.
I'm sure I don't,
I'm not able to talk to them.
I'm not in contact with them.
You get any messages from anyone else to
him or her or him to you?
I've been told by his attorneys that
he's healthy and he's in good spirits.
Um,
I know he's continued to work and
provide information to water.
Uh,
apparently,
uh,
the ioc,
he will be providing information to the
olympics as part of their investigation.
Um,
I've been told that he's worked with
global authorities and global police
agencies to help provide information
because he has so much information,
not just about Russia but of all sorts
of other things that were going on of
bribes and payments being made.
And you know,
I'm not a,
you know,
I don't know what evidence in that
regard that he has,
but he at least has the,
you know,
he knows so much and I know that he has
been working.
I'm a effoRtlessly through his legal
counsel to provide this information and
to work with global authorities to work
with water.
Uh,
now hopefully,
uh,
the ioc,
the olympics,
um,
us authorities.
Um,
but,
you know,
I don't know what his life's gonna be
like.
Yeah.
that's,
I
don't know if in one hole ever be able
to see his,
uh,
his family.
Um,
we launched,
uh,
a month or so ago if anybody's
interested on my,
um,
on my twitter page,
uh,
we launched a go fund me for gregory,
through an organization called fair
sport.
Um,
that fair sport was launched by,
uh,
one of the producers on my film and,
and a guy by the name of johann koss
who's been a huge advocate and
anti-doping and spirit fair sport was
basically launched to help other
whistleblowers in sport come forward
with information,
but also to help,
uh,
gregory in this ongoing battle.
We're being told that we need to get
that he needs to get money to his wife
for a,
for an attorney,
for legal help.
And she's stuck in russian passport
awaY.
They won't let her leave.
That's what we're being told,
uh,
we're,
you know,
so he has a,
incredible legal bills and other,
uh,
help that he needs.
ANd so we've launched this go fund me to
try to,
to try to provide him a lifeline over
the next years,
years.
um,
because,
you know,
his,
his future is so uncertain.
I mean we're,
where's he going to live,
how's he going to live,
how's he going to pay his bills?
And,
and he wants to continue to,
um,
you know,
be,
kind of frank aboriginal,
you know,
a guy who had committed wrong doings,
but he was under the orders of the
ministry,
but he has a lot of information that he
risked his life to bring forward to the
world because he felt a,
a,
a huge burden to,
to do this and he wanted to do this.
This was his,
this was his doing.
And ultimately he entrusted me as his,
a conduit to bring this story forward.
And,
and also gregory has attempted suicide
in the past.
So you're,
you're an under much less dire
circumstances.
Yeah.
He's essentially a wanted man right now
with no freedom.
I mean he,
uh,
he's in hiding and the russians most
likely
dead absolutely.
Um,
you know,
you see on this response to his New York
times op ed that they would,
um,
there had been a lot of,
a few followed the news and Russia.
They had already taken lots and lots of
action against him to,
you know,
kind of silence him to,
to make him irrelevant in the film.
I think one of the most moments
and um,
was as a,
at the end of every year a putin gives
a,
a huge press conference with hundreds of
journalists and,
and the doping scandal gets brought up
of course.
And he goes,
and this is just,
you know,
six months ago goes,
oh,
the guy who defected,
the citizen who defected,
uh,
the scientists,
I don't even remember his name.
And you're literally going there.
Are you kidding me?
putin just says he doesn't remember
gregory's name yet.
Yet gregory dominated russian news for
the past year.
He has been front page story for first
solid year.
This has been the single biggest scandal
and sport and in russian history,
he's arguably the biggest whistleblower
in the history of Russia and you have
the president of a country saying he
doesn't even remember his name and what
that is is that's george orwell,
1984.
That's double think.
That's essentially fake news.
That's pretending that by not
acknowledging you know him is not to
acknowledge the truth and that is what
is going on in this world.
And so here you see the potent look
straight to the camera and say,
I don't even remember gregory's name.
I mean that would be the equivalent of
of,
of asking an american who's our
president right now,
and somebody saying,
I don't.
I don't remember his name.
I mean that is that as the level of lies
and deception,
and then you see their reaction to the
New York times op ed by issuing an
arrest warrant for gregory to again
paint him as a criminal to again pretend
that this didn't happen.
To again,
try to obstruct the truth and shift the
focus away from the truth and the
punishment and what all this evidence is
in his bravery of coming forward and
instead try to turn him into,
into a criminal.
Uh,
so it's,
um,
it's,
it's startling and it's a.
And it's incredibly upsetting.
It was one of the reasons why we,
you know,
really latched onto 1984 orwell in the
film because everything that is that is
gregory's life was double thing,
but everything that's going on in our,
in our geo political cycle and with
Russia and putin,
it's,
it's double think it's,
it's the,
the truth is no longer the truth.
And you don't know what,
what news to believe or what not to
believe.
This is obviously very unexpected for
you,
mean you set out to do one documentary
and another thing reveals itself in the
middle of it and something incredibly
serious.
Well,
what is the impact of this been like for
you?
I mean the weight of this all carrying
this around with you?
It's been a lot,
uh,
from the,
from november of last year when gregory
to
los angeles to us ultimately going to
the New York times and um,
in may of last year,
May,
2016,
uh,
there was about a seven month period
where myself and my,
uh,
my producing partner,
dan cogan with impact partners and uh,
uh,
my other producers,
jim swartz and david fiasco,
um,
we had this information in the 70
[inaudible] and we knew what this was
and we knew how big it was.
And so was this period of about seven
months of a daily crisis navigation of
a,
how do we keep this information
protected?
We moved our production offices three
times.
We moved gregory into different safe
houses.
You move into production offices.
Could we didn't know if we were under
surveillance?
Did you feel like you're under
Felt like we were under surveillance?
Yeah.
What was giving you in done indication?
It was,
you know,
we'd see like a car.
I'm gregory who was not in protective
custody at the time,
uh,
was getting information from his people
out of Russia that they were,
you know,
that they were looking for him,
that they were,
you know,
a concerned,
um,
and,
and we knew the gravity of what this was
like.
I,
I underStood once I dove into this
evidence with gregory how big this was,
like,
what,
what this truly meant.
Um,
and,
uh,
and that I felt that,
you know,
Russia and the olympics,
but Russia would probably do anything at
all costs to try to,
you know,
not have this come forward because what
this meant and it meant that their
olympic games were fraud and that they
had been cheating global sport for the
entire modern history.
Um,
and uh,
and that it showed the extent to which
Russia and the ministry was willing to,
you know,
to,
to tamper in international affairs,
not just sport.
And so I,
I understood that and gregory understood
that.
And so it was a daily crisis management.
We went through about five months where
we couldn't even get them a lawyer
because every law firm that we would go
to would have some sort of confLict of
interest with russiA.
Um,
we uh,
couldn't.
It was,
it was a really,
really intense.
And during that time,
two of his friends die within two weeks
of each other of heart attacks at age 52
and 59.
And nikita kumbaya of who's 52 years old
and he's running,
he had resigned from running the russian
antidoping agency.
So,
so technically the russian anti-doping
agencies shouldn't be working with
gregory's lab,
the water,
the world antidoping agency lab,
those should be two independent things.
But these two were working together
because there was never any anti-doping.
Russia was the anti anti doping system.
Posing is anti-doping.
So nikita is still in Russia.
he's been forced to resign and gregory
and him are still talking via,
uh,
via skype.
And nikita tells gregory that he's going
to go,
but he's writing a book and that he's
been in contact with David Walsh.
And David Walsh is the sunday times
journalists that chased armstrong for 10
years.
He's probably one of the most renowned
famous sports journalists in the world.
The stephen frears film,
the programs based on David Walsh and
send to kieta had reached out to David
Walsh and him and David Walsh.
We're making a plan to meet.
And nikita had told gregory that,
you know,
he was going to meet with David Walsh.
Gregory was like,
this is,
you can't do this.
You're still in Russia and nikita,
you're still in Russia.
What are you doing?
And a day later,
nikita dies of a heart attack.
And this was a guy who was healthy.
A had never had a heart problem in his
life,
was a,
it was a lifelong athlete.
Never when he was 50 2:52,
and apparently he died over about three
and a half hours.
Well,
a nikita's wife was on the phone to
gregory crying.
Uh,
so this is a really have any suspicion
of how they did it.
Um,
you know,
gregory goes out and they just,
you just die of a heart attack.
They poisoned yo whatever they,
you know,
I don't know how they do it,
but you know,
Russia isn't like isis.
They don't do something and then take
responsibility for obviously,
you know,
there's been so many stories like in
buzzfeed last year,
then have the 14 deaths in london,
all tied to,
you know,
various had the series of Russia.
There's been multiple books written on
it.
Um,
even,
uh,
you know,
which was not widely reported.
The russian agent that offered a,
apparently the trump dossier with the
[inaudible],
the former of my six agent,
uh,
he was found dead in the back of alexis
about five months ago outside of moscow.
Um,
so,
you know,
clearly they,
they,
they play by a diffeRent set of rules.
And,
um,
so this is all going on as we're
figuring out how to bring this story to
the world.
and,
um,
the,
our,
our government,
the us government gets involved with
department of justice and fbi.
They started investigating and um,
we realized that,
uh,
that we have to bring this story public
and that it's the best way for gregory
to hopefully be protected and uh,
and that once it's public,
it's,
it'll be in the world.
And,
uh,
so we brought,
to the New York times with gregory and
sat with them for three days and then
they broke the story and then,
uh,
as a film,
we then followed that story as it,
as it unraveled.
But,
um,
yeah,
it's been a,
it's been very,
it's been very heavy and uh,
I'm very worried about gregory and also
a incredibly frustrating to see that,
um,
what you kind of read about conspiracy
novels and you read about and you know,
all these guys who believed that,
you know,
uh,
everybody,
you know of how the system works and
then getting to witness this firsthand.
Uh,
and also I think as an athlete having
kinda my olympic ideal of what the
olympics is being shattered and seeing
that this organization really has no
regard for,
for anything other than their own
business interests.
Now,
how much time does gregory hAve in
protective custody?
they do.
They have a determined time period where
they're willing to protect him.
I mean,
it's the us government is protecting
him,
I assume,
um,
to my understanding,
you know,
that is a,
that that is the case.
But,
um,
I am not being given a updates,
and uh,
and I don't,
you know,
I,
I don't want to have that informatIon.
Um,
but,
uh,
you know,
I,
I'm very optimistic that whole continue
to be okay and that,
uh,
and that also with,
if something were to go wrong,
we'll be able to help him with that,
um,
you know,
through his counsel and team.
Um,
but it's,
it's certainly very concerning.
um,
you know,
I think he,
he clearly understood the risks before
coming forward.
Um,
we had tried to get his family out of
Russia and they didn't understand the
gravity of the situation,
um,
which I'm sure they do now.
and,
um,
you know,
I don't,
uh,
I don't know.
I mean,
he's a,
uh,
you know,
in the film,
you fall in love with them.
You just fall in love with this guy and
you see him for who he is,
whIch was incredibly important for me as
the filmmaker and as his friend was.
I knew that it would be very easy to
paint him into an illusion of somebody
that he wasn't some despicable guy doped
all the russians,
and then what you see in the film is
truly this loving kind character who
essentially is caught up in a,
in a system that he helped perpetuate,
but he certainly didn't create and that
he is ultimately an employee of the
russian government.
And uh,
and he was doing his job and that was
his job.
It's a,
it's such a complex issue.
And when you put all the pieces out on a
table and you just,
you've taken into account all the
different variables with doping and
trying to catch these people and what
the future holds.
And then what you were talking about
with epo,
with some sort of a biological way to
get your body a genetic way to get your
body to reproduce the same sort of
chemicals.
It,
it seems like there's no real solution.
Like you,
you'll lay it all out and you look at
what happened in sochi.
You look at what's going on right now
with the olympics,
allowing the russians still competing in
the brazilian games.
Even after all this and just not.
It doesn't seem like,
Oh,
this has to happen.
Or oh,
you just put this over there.
You just look at this big mess.
And he go,
where,
where does this go?
you know,
I,
I think that that is a,
a valid question.
And because when you,
when you start to look at where it goes,
first of all,
I really believe in,
you know,
the concept behind clean sport.
Like I really,
I really believe in that and I believe
that,
um,
that athlete should go and,
uh,
and compete clean because those,
those are the rules.
I mean,
you know,
you,
you come from bma world and all men,
you know,
you're going into a fight.
You at least it's enough of a fight.
It's a fight that had at least,
you know,
you want to believe that you're shaking
the guy's hand and that and that if he
kicks you out,
if he kicks your ass,
he kicks your ass.
But he did it through hard work,
through hard work and planned by the
rules,
you know,
and,
and that's the,
the,
the concept I think that fans go into
watching sports and that athletes in
general go,
go into,
go into sport.
Um,
and,
but we have the flip side of that,
which is,
you know,
human beings are in a constant.
We're not done evolving.
Um,
there's a,
a great,
a philosopher,
futurist,
but he's also an investor.
His name's juan and rica as if you've
seen his ted talks and stuff and,
and,
uh,
really interesting.
And he geTs into how,
uh,
and he makes this whole scientific
argument about how human beings are not
done evolving.
The,
we're just not done involvement.
We believe that we've done involving,
but he shows through history how we're
not done evolving just like we went
from,
you know,
frOm neanderthals and humans and done
it,
you know,
and he goes through the whole history of
it and he shows how basically humans are
not done evolving and part of that not
being done evolving as we're constantly
figuring out how to live longer.
We're,
I sat with a guy yesterday who said the
problem isn't whether or not human
beings are going to start living to 110
or 120 years old.
The problem Is,
is that we're figuring out how to,
how to keep our body healthy,
but we haven't figured out how to keep
our minds healthy and that all of these
people that are going to be living
longer lives.
There's the problem with alzheimer's now
and dementia that you know,
even though you live longer
life,
your,
your brain is still deteriorating.
The point being is that we're in it.
We're in an age of,
of medical and scientific technology
that every single day is another
invention.
Another advance and you know,
for $200,000
or whatever it is right now,
uh,
in the embryo,
you can change your kid's eye color.
You can go in and decide that your kid
is going to be six foot and I'm five
[inaudible] eight,
you know,
I mean,
wow,
I would have loved my parents do have to
have to have seen to it that,
that,
that I was six feet tall,
um,
you know,
and all these kinds of things that are
going on right now.
And in the medical science and
technological advancement world,
um,
there were also things that the world is
going to have to start figuring out what
they do on the fields of play and
athletic because the humans of the
future,
um,
are going to be better versions of,
of what we have right nOw just through
science,
just through technology.
And then the question again goes into
the world of what's clean,
what's not clean,
what's,
you know,
what's anti-doping,
how do you police sport.
And those are very hard questions to
answer.
Yeah,
they really are.
And you don't.
On one hand,
you don't want to stop medical
technological progress,
right?
You don't want to stop people from being
able to cure diseases and it's almost
like some of the technology that they
use for aerospace makes its way into
everyday use or some of the technology
that they're going to use for all these
different medical innovation.
So there's different ways to cure
diseases and increase human performance.
They're gonna make their way into
athletics and it's going to be a very
blurry line.
But you know what is natural,
what's not natural.
I mean,
if your parents decide to genetically
all to you in the womb and change you
into a super athlete,
is that your fault?
And if it's not your choice or your
fault,
should you be allowed to compete.
That was always the argument about
carolyn,
you know,
alexander and his parents were like
five,
five and five,
six.
They were these tiny people and he was a
fucking giant and a gorilla and they
used to call him in Russia.
They used to call him the experiment and
if you look at corella and you look at
him physically,
I mean there's very few athletes you're
ever going to see that look like that
guy.
I mean,
he was close to 300 pounds,
move like a cat,
and would literally launch grown men
through the air.
They were so terrified of his physical
prowess that grown men used to flatten
out on their stomach and literally try
to cling to the earth to avoid being
thrown by him.
Are you aware of him?
No.
Look at this motherfucker.
Yeah.
He was undefeated in,
in the olympic games up until rulon
gardner beat him who was an american and
who to go to that picture which shows us
full body,
which shows his legs and that image.
There's a black and white that have up
there now that there,
uh,
several,
I forget when he took.
This is all.
No,
no.
Go to the.
There's a full,
full image of that.
Jamie [inaudible] try to find that image
on the right.
but there's a full one where you get to
see his entiRe build.
I mean,
he was a fucking freak and so his thing
was throwing these men and he's a
heavyweight,
sO these guys are 300 plus pounds.
He would throw them through the air like
in a way that very few people could do.
Look at that picture of him with his arm
raised right below that,
the black and white.
He was fucking monstrous.
Wow.
And without a doubt,
choose to the tits.
I mean,
no question about especially given the
information that was disclosed in your
documentary.
I mean this was all,
I believe.
I believe he was through the eighties or
the nineties and into the early two
thousands when he retired.
But um,
I mean he was a freak of all freaks and
the most terrifying man and all of a
russian amateur wrestling for sure.
Everybody was afraid of him.
This is him standing above the greatest
mixed martial arts heavyweight of all
time.
Fader,
a million ankle.
And you'd see how much bigger he is in
fader.
The,
he was a fucking giant with the cv.
You could find a picture of him with his
parents
because it was the.
And the story was always that he was
basically a genetic mutant.
well,
the day did something,
I mean,
no one mean it was so long ago.
It's very difficult to ascertain what
was capable,
what was possible back then.
But his performance in wrestling was
just stunning.
I'm obviously trained hard,
obviously very skilled.
I mean,
one of the things about russian
wrestlers is not just the fact that
their physical prowess,
but they're incredibly technical.
Some of the most technically advanced
wrestlers in the world in terms of their
tactics and the way they would drill.
I mean they really had it down to a
science and there was so much gravity to
it all.
It was so,
so important.
And on top of that choose to the tits.
So there was so many factors that came
into play.
And uh,
when you're talking about this state
sponsored russian doping program,
I mean,
you have to really think and include
corella and in that because he was just
a massive,
massive part of it.
Yeah.
I'm sure you know when people have
always speculated for for many years
like fate or who is arguably the
greatest heavyweight of all time was a
competing and pride,
which was an openly dirty leak when
pride was opposite the ufc.
The ufc had very rudimentary testing at
the time.
What they would essentially do is do
urine testing at the way in which a
victor conte famously said is just a.
An intelligence
tests.
I know,
I know victor.
Yeah,
well,
I got to meet him.
I got to know him pretty well through
this.
He had victory to the podcast a few
years back and was talking about,
and this is pre usada now the ufc is
hired,
saw to individ ski and jeff novitsky has
done a fantastic job and unfortunately
just caught John Jones who won.
We won the title,
knocking out daniel cormier.
They stripped him of his title and now
cormier is going to be the champion
again.
That's.
It's so fucking confusing and distorted
because in,
in mixed martial arts,
as opposed to any other sport,
even wrestling,
wrestling,
your health is on the line,
but nowhere near as much as it is in
mixed martial arts.
So the cheating,
it's not a matter of a guy getting
across the finish line faster than you.
It's a matter of a guy landing blows or
woman lending blows that they would not
have been able to land had they not been
cheating.
And it gets very,
very tricky because you're talking
essentially about not just illegal
activity,
not just cheating,
but potentially assault.
And what if someone dies,
like,
what if someone is doping and it's
proven that they're doping and the
beating they give their opponent leads
that opponent dying.
You can make a real argument that
manslaughter charges at the very least
should be filed if not murder.
Yeah,
I mean,
uh,
it's certainly the implications are met.
So you could certainly make that
implication and you know,
and in this story,
even the,
the idea wheRe you have thousands of
athletes essentially waking up and
going,
wait,
maybe I would've,
I would've gotten metal and how diana
metal,
what would be different in my life
today,
which changed their whole world.
It's changed the whole world.
It's,
it's,
and that is why you know,
this,
this problem is so I think hard and
difficult to combat because when you
look at what is at stake,
the,
the economics at stake,
but you know,
the,
the box of wheaties essentially that,
that,
you know,
going in and nobody remembers,
remember second place.
It doesn't mean anything to me.
Anything.
It means nothing.
It's all one win or you don't.
Yeah,
you win or you lose.
And if you win comes all the,
you know,
uh,
spoils.
And if you'Re not the winter,
you might as well have almost never been
there.
Well in indifferent than the other
athletic endeavor endeavor because
essentially it is their life,
but it's not professional.
Which is a really weird thing because
you have so much money involved.
the olympics,
billions and billions of dollars are
going into the hands of people who don't
even fucking compete,
which is insane.
It's unlike any otheR athletic pursuit.
If you look at professional sports,
I mean whether it's the nba or boxing or
what have you.
The vast majority of the money goes to
the athletes themselves right now,
not in the olympics and the olympics.
Fucking zero.
No,
it's just insane.
It's like college basketball.
It's insane.
Oh,
it's purely an honor to be in the
olympics to go to the olympics and the
athletes themselves,
you know,
and this is why it's actually you're
able to understand a state sponsored
system,
which I think the american mentality is
hard to understand because here we're
looking at $205,000,000
nba contracts and sport is privatized
and the athletes get paid and that even
when you go to the olympics as an
american athlete,
you might be competing for America,
but America is not paying your way to
the olympics.
You're nOt on the us payroll.
Michael phelps is not being paid by the
us government to go compete in the
olympics,
but in China,
in Russia,
in a an any essentially,
you know,
post communist,
communist,
any,
any sort of country like that.
The athletes are employees of the
Government and they're essentially state
employees and their job is to go and
compete for their country and they're
being paid to do so
and the the spoils are so incredibly
large for the athletes,
even in America that people are still
going to be willing to put it on the
lawn and compete because you could be
that Michael Phelps guy that winds up
getting incredibly rich and famous from
winning the olympics.
So people are willing to compete and
essentially risk their physical body
risk all of their time,
their effort,
their dedication to try to accomplish
something that all the world's going to
be watching,
massive profits being made and they
don't see a fucking penny of it unless
they win.
That's right.
When they.
It's a consequence of them winning that
they see that.
Exactly.
But if a win,
if you're simone biles,
if you're phelps,
if you're any one of these athletes and
basically sport that people don't really
watch and there's money behind any
other,
any other time of the year other than
the olympics,
every four years people care about
gymnastics.
They don't care about gymnastics any
other time.
But once every four years,
everybody cares about jim.
Now who's watching swimming.
Exactly.
Nobody gives a fuck.
Nobody cares about swimming.
But once every four years they care
about swimming.
And if you can go in and capitalize on
that,
you have a live.
It's just so if you don't,
you don't.
I mean that's the whole kind of
armstrong a basketball player for the
Australia team.
He's actually an mba player putting
together a shower curtain for his.
Wherever he was staying in on the side
here,
describes the 196,
a cabin,
nine index super ship that the men and
women's us basketball teams were staying
on and had 250 police officers watching
them.
And I didn't say who paid for that
either.
Well enough.
They paid for their own know.
Who knows?
But the point being that the olympics
are essentially a professional endeavor
where the athletes,
the ones who people are watching are not
getting any of that money and it's a,
it's a dirty organization in that regard
because this is not amateur.
It was amateur.
The world would see it for free.
I mean it's not.
you have to pay some money.
I don't know how many billions and
billions and billions of dollars.
I can't.
The contract could staggering what nbc
paid for the olympic rights for the next
however many games it is.
Yeah.
And what they get paid from the
advertiser.
And that's just the us.
Yeah.
That's just you.
So on a global level,
this is the most watched sporting.
This is the most watched event on planet
earth.
Nobody world cup soccer and the
olympics,
but the olympics even more so most
watched event on planet earth.
And it's,
there it is,
seven point seven,
$5,
billion through 20,
bc paid.
Wow.
stunning.
I mean it's,
I don't know what the solution is,
but it never.
It never sent set right with me.
I always felt like it was gross.
I mean,
it just didn't make any sense that
everyone is getting paid,
but the athletes,
it's a,
it's essentially,
they've,
they've managed to keep it this way.
They had this situation in place a long,
long time ago,
and then it became this massive global
business is huge empire and they managed
to keep the athletes out of the loop.
It's,
it's really,
it's really a mess.
And,
and not only that,
there were so many people that have
profited to the tunes of millions and
millions of dollars through the
essentially bribery of other countries
into,
you know,
all the politics behind that to protect
their athletes so that the athletes can
continue to,
to win medals.
I'm gregory told me a story,
Um,
whIch i,
I wonder when this will come true
because I certainly can't verify it,
but he told me a story of a former
olympic medical director and the guy
apparently,
uh,
was the head medical director of the
olympics for like 15 years or something.
And according to gregory,
this gUy liveS in a,
uh,
an Incredible chateau,
a somewhere in,
uh,
in Switzerland.
It's like a mind boggling house.
And um,
um,
and he's lIke an orthopedic doctor,
but he's the head medical director of
the olympics and according to gregory,
he's accepted millions and millions and
millions of dollars in bribes,
uh,
through different countries to conceal
positives over all these various olympic
games that whatever it was,
you know,
uh,
Slovakia or whatever,
there'd be a positive in this guy would
get a half a million dollars to conceal
it.
There's a positive here and he'd take
the money and conceal it.
And uh,
and uh,
I wouldn't be surprised if that's,
I'm sure it's just the tip of the
iceberg because this is huge money in
these countries are willing to pay this
big money because for a country like
Russia or China or,
you know,
even Jamaica,
right to win medals,
what that does for its country on a
world level.
All of the sudden when jamaica's winning
medals,
everybody's going,
wait,
we,
we want to go to Jamaica.
I mean,
just what that jamaican team did
probably did for tourism dollars to
Jamaica,
if you could add.
I mean,
it's staggering,
right?
It made Jamaica and victor conte,
we'll talk about this,
you know,
in detail how the fast five fastest
runners on planet earth are jamaican and
content will go right.
And don catlin goes,
yeah,
right.
But,
but look at the money that,
that had to have brought Jamaica of the
tourism,
of advertising,
of,
of interest of everybody's going,
wait,
I want to go to Jamaica.
Oh,
I should go to Jamaica.
I should go see,
you know,
where,
where did these peOple come from?
Yeah.
where did they come from?
You know,
when a fader was the king of the world
as far as the heavyweights in mixed
martial arts,
I,
putin was regularly at his fights and it
was always like this big deal that putin
was there and fado with smash these
people,
especially when fate or fought in Russia
and um,
you know,
I mean,
it's a massive,
massive deal to have a top fighter or
top athlete representing your country.
I mean,
it's just a huge deal for,
for you to have the number one guy.
Oh,
absolutely.
I mean,
you look at,
you know,
I'm like a sharapova,
and uh,
um,
you know,
gregory would,
would tell me stories of,
you know,
how many he knew for years would,
would,
what she was taking,
what she was up to.
He was advising her family.
I'm just a according,
according to him,
she even lied about her age.
I don't,
uh,
that apparently the age that she was
playing at that she is reported as a,
uh,
as a couple of years younger that,
that was all part of Russia helped with
that.
WAsn't there a situation with serena
williams were the testers came to her
house and she locked herself in a safe
room and called the police.
Oh,
I didn't hear that one,
but yeah,
it was,
it serena or venus was serena.
See if he could find that story.
Yeah.
The task force showed up at her house
and she's like,
not now,
motherfucker click locked yourself in a
safe room.
You got to think about the amount of
money that's involved in these things.
And you know,
if you know that other people,
serena williams lOcks herself in panic
room and drug test mix up.
Oh,
it's just a mix up.
Ladies and gentlemen,
that our los angeles manchin,
no worries.
Mansion.
The tennis legends assistant at 6:00
AM local time last wednesday and told
the emergency operator that a prowler
had been spotted at the luxurious
property.
She retreated to her panic room and a
bid to protect herself for that is where
they are Giving her every benefit of the
doubt.
and that one,
I mean it's,
it's hard.
It's really.
But the intruder train hold on,
turned out to be a random drug test who
stopped by unannounced for a urine
sample to.
Well you the cops responded on them on.
But the quickly left the property when
the misunderstanding was discovered,
it was not known whether or not william
submitted to the drug test.
Well that's.
yeah,
I mean she didn't.
If it's not known that means she didn't
or potentially in the panic room,
but lots of saline solution.
But I couldn't imagine if you're
thinking about the amount of money that
a certain person who is a world renowned
athlete in whatever sport it is,
I mean the amount of money that's
involved as fucking staggering.
And if you have stringent drug testing,
you know,
that's why the John Jones,
it was so disheartening because jon
jones,
who's arguably,
if not the greatest mixed martial arts
fighter of all time,
he's number two,
you know,
maybe mighty mouse is number one.
But you would say that mighty mouse is
not faceless kind of competition that
john has.
So that would put john into number one,
a lot of people's eyes.
But to have him test positive like that
was so disheartening for people and just
such a heartbreaker because people had
just hoped and prayed that,
you know,
him coming back and winning that way.
Like maybe he'll get his shit together.
You know,
when you see a guy with massive
potential and he's been involved in all
these fuck ups in the past.
Maybe finally he's got his shit together
or maybe what happened is he is.
He came back and he realized that he was
never going to be what he was going to
be and that whole psychology kicked in
and I think he,
you know,
you see that in,
in,
in so many guys.
I think that once you've been on that
program or you understand that program,
I think it's probably very,
very hard psychologically to go off of
it.
And also,
you know,
you're always going to be pushing those
limits.
It's always the,
the icarus story.
Um,
there's um,
you know,
an,
an armstrong,
uh,
in 2009 when he staged that comeback.
Um,
you know,
I,
I believe that he was trying to do it
clean and then all of a sudden realize
he was gonna get his ass kicked,
doing a clean.
And you look at that comeback here,
which is so interesting that contador
who beat him set the all time fastest
times in that year.
And that was supposed to be the clean
tour.
That was the redemption tour.
That was the tour to approve that.
It's clean.
And yet in that tour,
a contador set the all time,
fastest times.
And funny enough that year were
armstrong got third,
um,
had he been doing the tour any other
year,
the watts per kilo that he had put up,
the power that he had put up,
it was actually his best tour ever,
ever.
So he came into that tour going,
I'm gonna win it.
And yet his teammate got the door and
schleicher I'll open them essentially.
And it was the end.
And so had it been any other year,
he would have won that tour.
It's so crazy.
And now with crispr,
you know,
now with this new technology that allows
people to essentially,
I mean it's the,
it's on the table what the potential is
going to completely play out,
but other countries are using it right
now and embryos and know whether or not
humans,
uh,
in the United States whether they're
going to use it and you're going to see
these children.
It's not when or it's not.
If rather it's more like when,
as this technology progresses and it
gets better and better,
if you find out that your children have
the genetic markers that could
essentially lead to alzheimer's down,
uh,
down the road.
Why would you want your children to have
alzheimer's?
You wouldn't,
you wouldn't,
you would edit them.
You would say,
well,
they'll say,
it's just a simple procedure.
It's no more dangerous than,
you know,
other medical procedures that we do
every day.
We're just going to do it.
It'd be real simple,
by the way,
which you have a preference.
Do you like your child to have a
ridiculous,
a vo two max?
Would you,
would you like your kid to be one of the
most ridiculous mesomorphs the world has
ever known?
Do you want to herschel walker type body
for your child?
Well,
they can do it.
Yeah,
The technology's there right now.
It's,
well,
it's close.
Technology's there right now.
I was reading all these articles right
now,
which is a funny.
silicon valley did a show with the blood
bags.
If you saw that episode where,
uh,
the gavin belson television show is,
is having his blood swapped out by like
a 21 year old and really good looking
kid.
Peter teal does that on a regular basis
and that was the,
and that was the lampooning of it,
but they've been doing all this test in
mice that if you take an old mouse and
give it the blood of a young mouse that
the old mouse starts,
you know,
basically reverse aging and if you give
the old mouse blood to the young mouse
that the young mouse turns into an old
mouse.
So I mean,
this is,
this is on the,
on the horizon.
I mean this is,
this is there.
So the question is what,
what,
what do you do about it?
I mean,
you're,
you're like a,
you know,
your urine enthusiasts and you're in the
sports that you care about or dangerous
violent sports.
So how,
what do you,
what do you do about it?
it's a real question,
you know,
it's like all those things we were
talking about earlier,
you put all the pieces on the table and
you try to imagine what's the solution?
I don't see the solution.
I don't know what it is because I don't
think we were talking about this with
some friends.
We were saying like if everybody decides
to stay clean,
but yet the technology becomes viable
for the average person.
You're going to have a mailman that
looks like the incredible hulk and
you're going to be watching these
scrawny guys fight in the ufc.
No one's going to tolerate that.
You know?
We're just going to have to assume at
some point in time that all these people
are enhanced.
We're just going to assume that it's
more than just dedication and hard work
and honestly it's going to be a sad day
when that happens because when that does
happen and we just accept the fact that
we've created these genetic freaks,
they're not going to be special.
It'S not going to stand out.
Like when you saw Mike Tyson,
it was a special thing because it was
the 19 eighties and there was really
nothing.
I mean who knows?
It's probably.
There was probably some steroids
involved in that too.
I mean there's the steroids involved in
a lot of different things that we've
just assumed there weren't little just
leave that on the table,
but it wasn't genetics,
which you saw as a guy who was born that
way,
who was born with that freakish power
and speed.
You didn't get it from a laboratory.
You didn't get it from somebody's
literally taking the embryo and altering
the genetiCs and the embryo and making
him a destruction machine,
making him a violent force of nature.
Like Mike Tyson was in his prime.
The idea that yOu could take a regular
person like young jamie over there and
turn them into some sort of crazy freak
athlete.
It's just.
It's weird because when a freak athlete
comes along,
you see them and you go,
wow,
that guy's a freak.
This is crazy.
No one can do that.
I've never seen anybody do that before,
but then you look at the money behind it
now and then you look at,
as in this film,
you see all of a sudden the geo politics
behind it,
but in the us or whatever were we're
looking at it on the,
you know,
the $40,
million dollar a year contract level of
it and whether or not that's ethical and
what do we do about that.
All of a sudden we have athletes has
genetic mutants and what is that future.
But then when you look at it on the geo
political level and what a country is
willing to do to win and what it means
for their athletes to win an assert
power.
I mean like I rememBer when,
you know,
a couple of years ago when Germany won
the world cup.
I mean it was a.
I mean,
german pride had to have been at a,
at a staggering level.
I mean,
you,
you probably could have went and went
into any bar in Germany and said
something,
you know,
and you would've got your face speeding.
I mean,
it is because of the emotion that people
get connected to with their athletes and
their sports team and I think
governments and in the case of icarus
and you understand what that is,
that this is,
this is so far beyond,
you know,
it goes into,
into global power and how do you
consolidate power and sport in many
ways.
Is that,
is that vehicle I see it.
Yeah,
certainly as.
I mean it's such a huge part of the
recreation of the people and giving
people something to be excited about.
Now when you,
you do take into consideration this new
technology that's on the horizon crisper
and,
and who knows what's after crispr,
right?
And then you look at what Russia has
been unwilling to do with their state
sponsored doping program.
You've got to think they were already
involved in that.
You gotta think they're already.
Well,
you know greg gregory said something to
me interesting is he says,
well,
you know,
whatever they put on that water list,
meaning whatever banned substances they
put on the list we've already got in
Russia,
we've already got another 10 or 20 that
messing with.
If you remember last year,
the whole meldonium scandal with
sharapova and all these assets as the
ufc gets freaked out for them,
they'll donate them.
Well,
that was a substance that Russia had
been,
you know,
messing with for years knowing that it
wasn't on the pan,
on the banned list.
And then they essentially put it on the
banned list like that.
And then they started testing for it and
they did it as a,
you know,
it was,
it was very intentional to go catch
everybody on meldonium.
But you know,
according to,
to gregory is,
there's,
you know,
they've already,
they're already figuring out the next
thing,
the next thing,
the next thing
well spent.
Especially when you have a state
sponsored program and there are no state
sponsored programs that we know of like
that in America.
I mean that would give them a massive
advantage.
No,
we don't.
We don't know of any program where.
I mean,
when you think about what that is,
it would be like the equivalent of obama
or trump,
you know,
going,
hey,
american athlete,
you need to be on this program.
If you're going to be on the national
team and represent America,
you go on this program and if you don't
want to be on this program,
well you're not on the team and uh,
and,
and what gregory was doing,
which was part of the whole ethical and
moral conundrum,
which is an interesting thing which we
never get into in the film,
is he was constantly being forced to
sacrifice athletes.
So part of this system,
the only way that it would work is you
had to have lamps.
If nobody ever tested positive,
right?
Well,
it would look like there's something
wrong with the system.
So they had to have positive tests and
they would consistently have positive
tests.
And the guys who would test positive,
what they would do is they were the guys
who either were past champions that the
ministry looked at and said,
hey,
you're not going to go and win another
gold medal.
You're not know you're not who you are
anymore.
Or it was an athlete who they believed
could be a champion,
never lived up to his potential and was
on the state program.
So they would sacrifice athletes along
the way to make it appear that the
system was catching them and,
and,
and that was a whole a conundrum for
gregory because he got to know a lot of
these guys and,
and these athletes would think that they
were being protected because they
thought that they were on the state
state program.
So they think that they're being
protected and all of a sudden they're
positive and they're banned and they're
going,
wait,
you told me you told me to take this and
um,
and what do you mean on band?
You told,
you told me I'd,
I'd be negative.
Be like your positive jesus.
Well they were always positive so it was
just a matter of,
of,
of who to sacrifice and whether or not
they would,
they would swap the urine.
He had this.
We never get intO,
into the,
into the film,
but this is mind blowing to.
So he had developed right after the,
the london olympics.
They figure out how to break into the
bottles.
Right.
So they,
they figure out how they can break into
these bottles and swapped the urine.
But he personally was never doing that.
what he would do is the fsb,
these guys would come in,
they had this device and like once a
week,
whenever they needed to do it,
they'd come in and swap out all these b
samples that they'd keep in storage,
you know,
just for safe keeping.
And the,
a sample was always swapped.
But the b sample,
they would like,
you know,
there wasn't going to be a need to
retest it right that moment.
So they'd keep it for a week or
whatever.
And then the guys would come in and they
would swap out all the samples.
So part of this system was as he kept a
urine database,
so he had 16,000
matching urine samples that he was
holding in the laboratory that they
should have all been disposed of after
three months according to the code.
So any international athlete that would
come into Russia to compete in the
games,
kids,
gymnast,
anybody competing in Russia.
And if they tested clean,
Russia would hold their urine,
put it down for the specific gravity,
the steroid profile,
keep it in a database,
you know,
the urine is being kept frozen so they
would always have samples to swap for
any of the russian athletes at any time,
even if they didn't have a clean sample
for that athlete.
So because most of the russian athletes,
they were on the program in sochi,
they took extraordinary precaution.
They collected clean urine of each of
the athletes on the program.
But outside of that,
what they were doing was just going,
hey,
we have 16 thOusand samples to choose
from.
So whatever is going to best match the
russian athlete to swap with,
we can take the urine of another
athlete,
you know,
a,
a clean athlete and make it look pretty
much identical to that russian athletes
because they could choose from 16,000
samples.
Wow.
So they had it all index as far as the
weight and index everything because they
have a color profile and everything was
crazy.
I,
I got to see a spreadsheet and then on
the eve of this investigation breaking
and,
and water's going to go raid this
laboratory and there's thousands of
missing samples and,
and then the report,
this report that's 335 page report
tryIng to remember it was something like
1400 samples are missing or 1400 samples
were destroyed.
Will the real number was 8,200
something.
It was truly 16,
18,
8,000
samples matching in two bottles,
16,000
samples and they had to bring in these
containers,
industrial trash containers and the dark
of night operation,
emptying out the lab and bringing all
these bottles to some industrial trash
where they dumped them and crushed them
and incinerated them.
Wow.
And so it was,
I mean this was,
this was a pretty nutty operation going
on and they did this for the collegiate
competition.
So the.
So the world junior track championships
were in Russia.
They did it for that.
They did it for the swimming
championships.
They did for everything.
So they were.
These were kids to any,
any of the,
any of the collegiate athletes.
It's amazing that all the athletes kept
her mouth shut,
no athlete got a bad conscience and
psych are,
can't do this anymore.
I need to come clean.
Well,
there's been athletes that have come
forward.
yeah,
I mean there's been,
whistleblowers has been.
There's been multiple ones,
but I think,
you know,
what you start seeing in that system,
which is very hard,
I think for an american to understand.
Um,
and we talked very openly against our
government.
You know,
what's going on in the current
administration.
You know,
people are very,
you know,
anti trump or,
or pro trump or anti obama,
whatever that mean.
That's what,
as americans,
we,
we do that and we had that mentality
won't in China and in Russia and other
countries like this go through communism
and everything.
That mentality neveR goes away.
The mentality is always that the state
can take everything from you.
They can put you in jail,
they can take your passport,
they can see your assets.
They can launch fake news against you.
They can put you in jail just like they
did to gregory just like they're doing.
And so everybody,
no matter how powerful they all had that
fear of the government in their mind and
what you See,
because I saw this firsthand in Russia
where I have some very wealthy,
very powerful russian friends and they
will never talk bad about the government
in public everywhere now off camera or
you know,
or whatever.
And closed doors one-on-one.
There'll be like,
yeah,
I dOn't,
you know,
they'll,
they'll tell you how it is.
But in public,
if among their friends in a social
setting,
there's always this belief that
somebody's watching you or somebody
might rat you out or somehow you're
going to lose your wealth or,
or you're going to cross the paths of
wrong person.
And that's what we've,
what we've seen in all these stories
year after year after year out of,
out of Russia.
And certainly,
you know,
other countries are,
the mysterious death of,
of kim jong,
il's brother,
et cetera.
They are operating under a system that's
ancient.
I mean,
it's,
this is the way people have Been
dictators for thousands of years,
but they're just doing it in the age of
information.
And they're doing it right under
everyone's nose.
Fake news.
Fear,
yeah.
They did a,
uh,
this,
this was interesting about two weeks
ago,
uh,
russia's trying to get reinstated for
the winter olympics or will not,
not reinstated.
They're trying to make sure that they
can go to the winter olympics.
So they release the story through
sputnik news and rt,
the russian,
you know,
times Russia today.
And they released this story that
mclaren,
the investigator in the film behind all
the gregorys evidence,
uh,
that mclaren is willing to forgive
Russia,
that he believes that there's errors in
his report,
um,
and that water believes that Russia
should be reinstated and allowed to go
to the winter olympics.
None of this is true and this is piCked
up by worldwide media.
It's picked up by papers all over the
world.
And Russia just put this out there
basically to fuel the fuel of the
propaganda.
And then,
you know,
next day mclaren's out there,
going,
that's not true,
but his press release was picked up by a
handful of outlets where the,
where the Russia released because of how
they're able to disseminate news went
global.
I always watch a guy like that.
And I wonder like,
you look at the russian administration,
it's in right now and you went,
how long can they keep that going?
And you would look at it in terms of
America,
like americans would revolt.
But like you were saying in Russia,
I mean,
our remember the story aBout some
russian oligarch who,
um,
spoke ill of putin and I don't remember
what the deal was that he was
discussing,
but they stripped him of all his money,
took his company away and put them in
jail.
Oh,
it wasn't that,
um,
uh,
not,
not met aveva I know who you're talking
to.
What's his name?
Is very famous as famous case.
Well,
he was the richest man in.
Yeah,
Russia at the time.
They just took his entire fortune,
locked them in a cell,
kept in there for years.
Then eventually released in,
which isn't even bolder move.
They're like,
look,
we just dismantled you and now we'll
just let you Go.
Now you're not going to do shit.
It's terrifying.
What do you,
what do you think?
Uh,
and after seeing the film and,
and what your salmon.
The brushes once richest man,
he had his last 170 million hit his last
million because it was the saint.
Go back to the top of the title jamie.
How hid his last hundred and $70
million.
So we,
uh,
you know,
how do you say his name for the other 14
point $8 million?
It's only money just fried after 10
years in jail.
Told journalists at a press conference
in berlin two days ago that he didn't
know how much money you had left.
leah need berber.
She do ski columnist for the russian
editorial edit addition to have dish.
And a forbes thinks he has an idea.
I don't know how to say his name.
Cote d'or called ski khodorkovsky grew
rich in Russia.
Freewill in the 19 nineties by acquiring
state oil assets due to do one point he
was ranked 15th and the forbes
billionaire list with a personal net
worth $15,000,000,000.
Hmm.
So yeah,
This is the guy and they put them in
jail for quite a long time.
Ten years,
10 years in jail.
And just let them go.
Yeah.
Don't,
don't,
don't mess with Russia.
But even the letting go thing,
it's just amazing that they just decided
to let them go.
Like they put them in jail,
took all his money and then go,
yeah,
the fuck out of here.
Yeah.
Well once he was no longer a threat.
But it's just.
And it's also a learned his lesson.
It's a let everybody know like this can
happen to you.
Yeah,
exactly.
And by freeing him but also like lets
them know like you see what happens,
you don't want to mess with us,
you're gonna pay the price.
Stunning.
What,
what,
what do you,
what do you make of what's going on in
the,
in the us right now with all the
allegations after seeing the film or
were.
Where's your head at?
Well,
I didn't put the two of them together
because when I was watching the film
essentially I was just thinking about
the anti-doping ramifications.
Um,
but I mean it's pretty obvious that if
they're doing this,
they're.
And there's seems to be a lot of
evidence that they have at least
attempted.
I mean there's a,
there were sOme new thing recently about
facebook ads,
facebook,
twitter at.
Yeah,
I mean there's definitely something
going on,
but we're doing it too,
you know,
we're doing it to them.
They're doing it to us.
It's essentially been a part of global
politics forever.
I mean,
we influence their elections and not
just there as we influence the elections
of countless countries all over the
world.
It's a look.
It's Gross.
It's disgusting.
and the only thing that I can think is
that with the information age that we're
currently experiencing,
I think I feel like we're in the
adolescence of this and that.
What's,
what seems to highlight this age is that
the distance between people and
information just keeps getting shorter
and shorter and the aBility to hide
things,
hide devious acts and hide money and
hide influence.
And hide manipulation seems to be,
it seems to be able to.
The people seem to be able to find out
things quicker and quicker now.
And I was having a conversation about
this the other day where,
where if it's,
you know,
I mean look at the instagram age and
facebook and everything.
Everybody seems to know everything about
everyone and that anything eventually
comes out in the end.
I think,
again,
we're experiencing the adolescents of
this.
I think there's gonna come a point in
time with an.
I believe it's going to be through
technological innovation that we're
gonna be able to read each other's
minds.
I think it's inevitable.
I think the idea of the internet,
if you went to someone in the 18
hundreds and told them one day you're
gonna,
be able to talk to your phone and ask
your phone,
you know,
a bunch of different questions that are
literally give you the answer.
They would go with the fuck as a phone.
Like,
what are you talking about,
man?
Like what are you crazy?
This guy's a crazy person.
You're talking about witchcraft.
No,
no,
no.
I'm talking about all the world being
connected and you'll be able to share
photos.
What's a photo will be able to capture
time with a small device in your pocket
and video as well with perfect sound and
you'd be able to download hundreds of
hours,
hundreds of hours of music and put it on
your phone.
You'll be able to listen to that.
They'd be like recorded music.
The fuck are you talking about?
This is just a couple of hundred years
ago.
I mean,
what are we goinG to experience a couple
of hundred years from now?
I think we're going to be able to read
each other's minds.
I think the idea that we're a way,
the way we operate now,
our operating system of language,
the way we communicate with each other
through mouth noises and that you have a
dictionary.
We understand what the noises are and we
are.
You say some things like the entire time
you've been talking here,
I have referred to my database of
information so I know exactly what he's
saying and yell.
Brian means this and he means,
as you're talking,
all the people that are listening are
doing the exact same thing.
I think it is entirely possible that in
the future we will swap that out for
some sort of universal system,
some sort of universal system that is
neurologically connected that we're
going to have something that is either
embedded into our minds,
embedded into,
into our brain itself,
embedded into our neurological system.
That's minority report.
Yes.
I mean it's just inevitable if
technology keeps going and We keep
progressing and there's no reason to
think other than some sort of a natural
disaster or some sort of a human created
disaster that it doesn't.
It doesn't keep going the way it's
going.
we're going,
we're going to get to someplace where we
can see each other's minds.
We're going to be able to read each
other's thoughts and for good or bad,
and I tend to think both.
Both good and bad.
we're going to long for the good old
days.
When you have some privaCy going along
for the good old days of you can keep a
secret.
No,
I mean,
because right now we're already in an,
in an era where almost anything is
discoverable,
anything,
you know,
nothing,
nothing is private anymore and there's
always something to come out and then
there's some sort of electronic trail of
it.
I mean even in the oe,
which we don't,
which I,
I,
you wouldn't know about the film,
but the way that,
that evidence was truly corroborate it
was the electronic trail and here's the
amazing thing,
which people probably don't realize it.
So like gregory,
when he comes to the us,
he had erased all of his phones because
he was under the ministry order to erase
everything.
And,
and what was happening was the athletes
were snapping a photo of their doping
control forms.
So that's how gregory would know what,
what number corresponded to what
athlete.
I mean,
this was very intricate how this was
going down because nobody in the lab,
you know,
which you know,
if you're the scientist and you're
getting armstrong sample,
you don't know what's armstrong sample.
It's numbered.
It's got a seven,
eight digit number on.
It's just a random number.
But so What the russians were doing,
they were snapping a photo of her doping
control form,
which only they could do,
right?
and then they were sending this photo to
a,
um,
an fsb agent who was also a coach and
she would send the photo to gregory and
the kgb guy in the,
in the lab who was assisting him and so
that they would know that that number,
number one,
one seven,
four,
corresponded to this athlete,
right?
The point that I'm getting at is that,
so he was erased all of that.
They told them to erase it all from his
phone,
all the computers,
everything.
And when he comes here,
he brings his old computer and he brings
his old phones because this guy,
he just knows and when he turns over all
the evidence to,
to water and the,
uh,
and the,
and the us authorities and interpol,
what they're able to do is they're able
to get all this erased information,
all of this array stuff that was on his
phone and computer and retrieve it.
Wow.
And that's like a massive portion of
this evidence.
Uh,
What they were also able to do is what
we probably don't realize,
and this goes into what you're saying is
when you send an email,
if you've got the,
the,
the metadata behind it.
So like he was getting emails sent
through the russian ministry.
So you're sitting there going,
well how do you know where this came
from?
They can go back in the actual,
through the metadata that is being sent
into computer and show exactly from what
computer,
where date time that email was sent and
that's how they were able to corroborate
all his evidence through,
through basically forensics of,
you know,
whatever,
whatever that study is of,
of electronic forensics.
So When you talk about reading minds and
that kind of stuff,
I mean half of that technology is,
is already there.
I mean,
any,
any photo you take on your phone,
even if you delete it,
they can get it back and they can figure
out exactly where you were,
where it was,
said how it was sent,
the spot that you sent it from where
it's nuts and it's going to get crazier.
Just going to get crazier.
I mean,
for sure there's gonna be some new
technologies to couple of years from now
that's going to make it even easier to
do than that.
And,
and when you read about,
you know,
there's all these apps with encryption
software and stuff and a maverick given
up the idea that,
that I,
you know,
that you can be essentially invisible or
they can,
uh,
you know,
that if somebody wants to get your
information,
they're going to get your information.
Yeah.
Unquestionably.
And you know,
another thing that's really interesting
is that we're looking at photos when
we're looking at video and email and
we're assuming that is going to be in
the future,
more access to photo,
more access to email,
more access to video.
But what,
what is coming down the pipe?
I mean,
what,
what is the new thing?
I mean,
there,
there could be something that's even
fucking crazier than video.
I mean we're just assuming that it's
going to stay video,
it's going to stay photos like why those
things didn't even exist a couple of
hundred years ago.
Well,
everything that's going on now is going
into this world of vr.
Yes.
Where essentially,
you know,
the,
the idea is,
is that as you can see things and you
can create your own reality.
I mean there's lots of discussion even
in the,
in the world of sex that,
you know,
the sex of the future is why do you
really need a,
a,
another human.
You can essentially simulate that and
program it and make it everything you
wanted and more.
I never know the difference.
Oh,
well,
I mean,
whether it's through augmented reality,
virtual reality,
robots.
I mean we're,
we're just a few steps away from all
this stuff and if it's not 10 years from
now,
it's 50.
If it's not 50,
it's 100.
I mean it's inevitable.
Human beings don't destroy ourselves.
We stay alive long enough.
We're going to see a complete desolving
of reality as we know it.
Which I think even goes into like the
whole anti-doping world of it in sports
where he,
you know,
a,
you actually just made me think about
like terminator,
where you're sitting there going,
well wait,
you think it's a real person and,
and,
and it's a terminator,
but you think of all the technologies
that are going on right now and why
won't there be a chip in,
in yOur brain that basically takes away
pain so that you can,
you know,
persevere in an mma fight that takes
away your,
you know,
all,
all these different technologies that
are essentially create,
you know,
controlling your synapses,
controlling your reflexes all it's all
there.
And how is that not gonna happen?
And then obviously in enhancing the
human body itself,
I mean there was a technology that we've
been talking about recently where they
were trying to combine spider silk with
human skin tissue to make an artificial
skin a replacement skin that's
bulletproof.
Wow.
That just blew my mind.
Yeah.
That just blew my mom there.
They're going to genetically engineer
human skin,
so it'll look like humans scan.
It'll have much of the same properties
of human skin,
but it'll be bulletproof because it'll
be you,
it'll be you.
You'll replace your skin,
and then how do they stop?
I'm in the power of that bullet would
still be up.
It did.
Well,
sure.
You could do some some tissue trauma
underneath the surface,
but the actual skin itself won't break.
It'd be like having a bulletproof vest
all of your body.
I mean,
that's what kevlar essentially is.
What cavalera is is a material that is
so dense and so it's so thick and so
impenetrable that when You shoot a
regular bullet into the regular bullet
hits,
it does not go through it and just
spreads out and expands.
It's still very painful for the person
who gets shot,
but it protects your life and we could
easily see that happen with entire
body's made out of that stuff.
I mean,
you got to believe it's priority out
there.
Like in some secret lab,
they are like develop the skin and
sitting in like a in like a petri dish.
That's bulletproof skin.
Yeah.
If I'm reading it on a sCience website
for sure,
I'm not the first one to get the
information.
I mean,
this is getting to the highest level.
where is the real money?
Right?
It's the real question is,
and I don't know this answer,
is the top scientists in the world,
the top innovators in the world.
I mean,
when do they scoop those people up?
When does the government come in with
some,
some black ops money and say,
hey,
we would like to hire you and give you x
amount of money to create this and this
is what we know so far about that and
you know,
here we're going to take you to groom
lake out in the middle of Nevada and
show you some lab that you didn't even
know existed.
Yeah,
but you got to beLieve it.
That's already way into going on because
there's nothing that we spend more money
on than military basically defense than
that.
This is what we spend money on.
That is actually,
you know,
I think,
uh,
as you probably know the,
I've read that the single biggest export
of the United States is our weapons.
Yeah.
That's what we make and sell to the rest
of the world.
Yeah.
We saw them and stuff.
It's not as good as the stuff we're
making right now.
Right now we sell the world our weapons
and that's,
and that is what is employing like
millions and millions of people in this
country is,
is basically the,
our military and our defense and
ultimately,
you know,
developing spider skin.
YeAh,
I mean this and this is what we're
seeing,
right?
This is what we get to see and look at
who knows how many different programs
are going on right now as we're speaking
that we have no knowledge of whatsoever.
I mean when they released the stealth
bomber and a couple other,
there's these like a sort of,
um,
experimental vehicles where they were
putting together these things once they,
they actually released them when they
actually put,
had press conferences and showed people
the,
they had been working on these things
forever.
It means
under wraps for like 20 years and all of
a sudden you see the singer like,
whoa.
Have you ever seen one person a stealth?
Yeah,
no,
I was in palmdale and that's near
edwards air force base and we were
filming fear factor out there and this
was right after September 11th and so
they were doing all these exercises and
these things were flying over the
desert.
It was like being in star wars.
I mean once you see them in real life,
you're like,
holy shit,
that's a fucking ufo.
this black thing not shaped like any
plane you've ever seen before,
flying across the sky and you just look
at it a little.
What the fuck is that thing?
Yeah.
That's like 20 years old now.
All the shit.
oh yeah,
for sure.
I mean about what's out there now.
I mean they probably have some
ridiculous stuff and then there's some
theoretical ideas.
You know,
the magnetic drives they're trying to
put together.
There's some.
I mean there's,
there's a bunch of speculation about
different types of weapons that they're
trying to,
to anti-matter weapons.
Some things that are going to be able to
just completely annihilate anything they
touch,
whether or not they're going to go
completely through the earth.
If you hit things and who knows,
who knows what's on the horizon.
I mean they're just going to keep
getting better and better at blowing
shit up.
You know what I mean?
The,
the amount of power that we have with
the nuclear arsenal today and the amount
of power and the weapons in comparison
to the weapons that we used in hiroshima
and nagasaki is insane.
It's not even close.
I mean there are hundreds and hundreds
of times more powerful.
No,
it's staggering to kind of understand
what kind of destruction is possible and
the like.
Nothing.
I don't think on the level of what we're
seeing in natural destruction of what
nature can do alone,
but.
But it's also fascinating when you think
about the,
that your,
your,
your film is sort of brought to light is
that a lot of this destruction,
like when you were talking about the
Ukraine,
a lot of this destruction and a lot of
this,
the confidence that they have to go into
these places and,
and use these weapons is kind of
dependent upon public opinion.
That's dependent upon sport,
rIght?
And be dependent on basically kicking
somebody else's ass without the weapons.
And then that allows you to almost like
weaponized because you have the,
the power of the country behind you,
you know,
it was a,
what was interesting is,
is um,
after sochi and putin's a rating goes up
to 95 percent or something like that,
that,
that everybody in Russia supported him
going into Ukraine too.
It was,
this was a good idea.
We're,
we're strong,
we're powerful.
Let's go in and,
and take back,
you know,
a part of territory that,
that,
that we lost.
So let's go do it.
And,
and,
and you see that,
that,
that sort of nationalistic pride is
real.
I mean,
I,
I grew up in,
um,
in Colorado,
which is,
you know,
denver bronco territory and uh,
I mean people would paint and they still
do.
I mean,
you know,
around football.
So you driving around the city,
you see thousands of houses painted it,
orange and blue people are in orange and
blue.
I mean it's,
it's literally,
it's a religion.
It's a cult.
It is,
it is an ethos.
It is.
and it's something to even fight about.
Like I'm in a,
you talk bad about the broncos were.
I mean that,
that's,
that's a,
that's a point of fight.
And,
and I remember,
you know,
the few years ago when the broncos won
the super bowl and you're looking at
like,
the statistic was something like 85
percent of the city of denver showed up
for a parade on a monday.
I'm like,
whoa,
this is crazy and this is what.
And this is what people.
So if you don't believe that that the
governor or whatever,
the governor of Colorado that day could
have been like,
hey,
we're going to go seize Montana,
Wyoming,
Arizona and Utah.
Everybody had state of Colorado would
have been like,
hell yeah,
go broncos.
Yeah,
I mean,
and that is,
that is what,
what this is masking behind,
you know,
a playing field.
I mean,
look at it,
it's just people care about this
[inaudible] you're basically beating
somebody else without weapOns.
See,
you're manipulating their opinions.
you're manipulating the way people feel
and public opinion.
What do you think should be done?
What?
How do you.
This is what I was sayinG before.
If you put all the pieces on the table.
I don't.
I feel like we're,
we're at a.
I don't think you can stop technology.
Right?
And I,
I don't,
I just don't think I,
I think it's what we do.
I mean,
I think if you,
if you looked at human beings as a whole
and you look at what we to be versus
what we are now,
if you were some sort of an objective
life form from another planet that
didn't have any vested interest in
understanding our culture and just tried
to examine us as a super organism,
what do we do?
We make better sHit every year.
That's what we do.
We're always going to make better shit.
We're always gonna make better shit as
long as we stay alive.
As long as we don't get hit by an
asteroid killed by a hurricane,
swamped and an earthquake or tsunami,
we're going to continue to make better.
We're going to continue to become better
humans technically,
tactically,
not maybe from,
hey.
I think even from a moral standpoint,
I think we're better now than we were
before,
which is why things like putin are so
disturbing,
which is what you know,
if you go back to like the gang is con
era.
It was the norm,
right?
That was how dictators ran.
That's how kings ran and emperors ran
their,
their dynasties.
It's more uncommon now and more
disturbing because the main superpower
doesn't do it that way.
The United States of America,
and that's one of the reasons why people
are so patriotic about America because
when you look back at human history,
we are the fucked up as we are
undeniably fucked up as it is.
We are the shining example of what's
possible in the future that we can keep
going and eventually create some sort of
a system that's different.
Some sort of a experiment in self
government has different than has ever
existed before where you can get to a
point where a fucking reality show
president or a reality show host becomes
the president of the United States of
America for good or for bad.
It opens people's eyes to the
possibility like,
wow,
like this.
This is a new thing like this.
In terms of human history,
this is a new thing.
This whole experiment,
this whole thing called the United
States.
It's only a few hundred years old is a
very new thing.
If you looked at us objective,
lee,
if you were something from another
planet,
you would say,
well,
what are they?
What's the end game with these fuckers?
What are they trying to do?
Well,
what they're trying to do is make better
and better stuff and I think the real
issue with that is artificial
intelligence because we look at
artificial intelligence,
we say the word artificial intelligence,
and we think of it as like a thing that
we can turn on or turn off.
We think of it as a,
a device,
a vcr,
or fucking television.
We think of it as a piece of equipment
that a human has created that may be
able to think for itself.
I think it's a life form.
I think it's just a life form that
exists from parts and pieces that we're
designed to put together.
I think our entire thing about being
attached to materialism are are constant
thirst for innovation.
We always want the iphone eight is
albert iphone 10 is around the corner.
Do you hold out or to get the new one?
Now you have two options.
No one's going to stick with the iphone
seven.
Fuck that man.
You know?
Well,
you're going to get the update.
The update is going to make it slower.
You know that happens,
right?
I mean,
we're,
we're thirsty for this shit,
but we'll.
We're fueling is innovation and
innovation will inevitably lead to a new
life form.
It's Going to lead.
We're calling it artificial color,
whatever you want.
It's fucking real.
It's not artificial.
It's just a life form that's not based
on blood and bones,
so life form that's based on circuits.
A lifelong is based on something that
human beings have created and once it,
once it can think for itself,
it's going to make better life forms.
It's going to make something way,
way different than us.
It's going to make something that
doesn't have any emotions.
doesn't have any biological needs.
It doesn't have any weird jealousy or
weird issues that have been holding us
back forever.
And what do you do with that?
Exactly when,
what?
What is it's motivation?
What?
Why does it even exist?
Why does it even want to do anything?
There's a lot of questions involved in
this and you know,
maybe it can find some sort of
motivation.
Maybe you can figure out some reason to
exist and to innovate and to keep going
better and better,
but we're.
We're limited.
We're limited by the scope of our
evolution.
When you look at and you're talking
about human beings haven't been run out.
Well,
that's getting into with,
with one henriquez which is,
which is,
you know,
we're his argument and I'd actually
interviewed him for the film and ended
up not using it because of where the
story went,
but his argument was not the moral
ethical argument around anti-doping and
sport.
It wasn't anything.
It was just purely the argument of,
hey,
look at evolution,
look at reality,
look at where we're gOing,
look at where human beings are
essentially transcending to and then how
do you ever have the basis of what is
the concept behind like clean sport more
or you know,
even transcending sport,
whatever you want to call it,
as being a pure ethos.
Because there are so many technoloGical
and really evolutionary variables that
are,
that seem to make that a fundamentally
difficult
and were resisting the future.
I mean,
it's almost like resisting performance
enhancing drugs is is futile in the
first place.
It's like foolish because these
performance enhancing drugs represent
technology.
The represent our ability to manipulate
our bodies recover.
Yeah.
And manipulate our biology.
Biology too.
Not just recover,
but also to grow at a rate that we've
never been able to grow before.
It's not just recover.
If it was just about recovery.
Some steroids allow you to grow at a
rate.
Look at bodybuilders like look like
freaks.
Like lee haney,
like when he was in his prime.
Yeah.
There's this,
that's not just about recovery.
That's also about growth.
It's also about,
I mean the speed that ben johnson had
when he won the gold medal and he tested
positive,
but it turns out that Carl Lewis was on
some shit too.
And they hid that.
I mean there's.
Yeah.
Camp catlin in 1984.
There were nine samples that went
missing to this day.
Yes.
And the story behind that is that the u,
s,
o c a came to,
came to don catlin because ca catlin had
found the positives and basically those
nine samples just vanished.
And you remember when ben johnson tried
to compete clean after that?
It was hilarious.
Yeah,
forget it.
It's like
you're looking at a regular guy trying
to race against superstars.
forget it.
He's like,
if I was running,
here's a.
Here's an interesting story.
I'm slightly off topic,
but on the topic of ben johnson.
So I'm dick pound Richard Powell.
What a great name.
By the way,
dick pound.
I mean,
how do you ever.
You cannot mess with a guy by the name
of dick cow.
Why did the fuck did he ever go with
dick when his name was richard?
Because I chose pound is that it does
what to it?
And just been like,
yeah,
hey,
I'm dick pound back in the day like dick
nixon just go through your life.
a video.
You introduce yourself to a girl like,
hey,
but you named dick pound.
But still they call it dick back in the
seventies and the sixties I think.
Yeah,
I mean Richard Nixon wasn't a dick.
No,
I guess all was his friends called him
dick nixon.
Yeah.
something.
Yeah,
buT that's not my point.
My point is,
was a penis called a dick?
I don't know
when.
When a.
When a penis became.
Okay.
Dick.
Yeah,
exactly.
I don't know.
I wonder if dick pound adopted the name
prior to penises or if he or when he
started calling himself dick pound.
Right.
he knew that it was a dick and then or
if he adopted it,
you know,
like post daycare or at what point?
He basically said,
yeah,
I'm going to be dick pound.
Well,
richard to dick is always a weird one
too.
It's not as weird as john did.
Jack.
John.
Jack is the weirdest one.
I mean kind of fucked you get richard
should be rich.
Yes.
Rich.
Go from.
Yeah.
How do you go from richard dick?
How do you go from john to jack?
Jack kennedy is John F.
Kennedy.
It makes no sense.
It doesn't make sense at all.
What about Jack Johnson?
Is he John Johnson?
I think he was jack.
I think his name was actually jack,
like you can have a name.
Jack johnson.
I'm not wearing it right now is we're
going to.
Earlier today I was wearing a Jack
Johnson t shirt.
This morning was funnier when you said
that I thought I still had it on.
So like this.
Hi.
So,
so,
uh,
dick pound,
a richard pound who actually founded
water at the time.
He's basically within the ioc and he'd
talk about a crazy conflict of interest
here.
So,
so richard pan was an,
an athlete,
a swimmer in olympics one.
We're actually.
And then he gone into being in the ioc
and he's a lawyer and his law firm has
been representing the olympics for the
last,
I don't even know how many years.
Thirty years in all of their sale of the
olympics to the entire world is Richard
pounds.
Lawford law firm,
striking pound number.
Japan is also the vice president of the
ioc and richard pound,
um,
establishes water.
He's the first head of water in 1999.
I'm now an interesting stories.
He's canadian and he is essentially like
the ambassador to Canada during the time
that ben johnson test positive and ben
johnson test
positive and Canada sends richard pound
in there to basically see if they can do
something to make this go away.
Is this true?
Can they,
is there some,
some way that basically ben johnson
cannot be positive and dick pound as he
will tell you was,
was,
was there essentially trying to
negotiate,
find a loophole on behalf of Canada that
ben johnson would not be positive,
but that apparently he was just so
radically positive and there was just
like,
there was nothing that anybody could do
about it.
It was just like a,
hey,
we'd really like to help you,
but this is really,
really bad.
there's a lot of drugs.
I remember an article that described the
whites of his eyes being yellow because
his liver was overwhelmed trying to
process the amount of steroids,
women's body.
uh,
I mean he argues that the coaches,
you know,
that he had no idea that they had always
just kept telling them to just,
you know,
it's fine,
you're fine.
Don't worry about it.
Might be true,
but I wonder what they really did think
was gonna happen or how they thought
they would pull it off.
Well,
I mean,
it was these kinds of scandals that
forced the ioc to create water.
The world antidoping agency [inaudible]
they looked at a brand and crisis.
And how were they gonna regain public
trust?
Because the year was this.
This was a lot.
It gets established in 1999.
If I remember ben johnson was a.
That was the,
uh,
not the 84 olympics.
It might've been the first olympics
where they tested.
Yeah,
that was the 84 olympics were ben
johnson was a,
uh,
was tested positive.
So maybe they just did,
but all the americans.
But according to everybody that I've
talked to,
the entire american team was positive
too,
was just so positive.
Too far.
You just,
you just pushed away to fuck.
But he looked like a freak to.
He was so jack,
he's so big.
It looks so different.
That stuff.
I mean,
we had a,
I think we have some footage of him in
the,
in the film at the end.
I mean he,
I mean he is a machine.
Yeah.
He looks so different than the other
track and field sprinter.
He has just a machine.
Yeah.
He looked like,
like an mma fighter.
I mean it was just fucking look at a
shocked look at that.
Guys still get Carl Lewis.
It's like,
shit,
I need a betteR doctor.
I mean he was jack.
Listen,
look at his shoulder there.
Everything.
Yeah.
shredded.
I mean Carl Lewis,
look at johnson and Carl Lewis was on
some shit too.
That's what's really crazy.
It's like all these guys were on some
shit.
I mean we have this idea like xyz.
Aida is a wearable for something like,
my god.
I mean we,
we have this idea that you'd be able to
tell looking at someone whether or not
they're on steroids.
That was always the idea.
Like the sniff test.
Well gregory,
the thing is I was
working with him over his son.
He'd run into guys and he'd be like,
he's on the hgh.
She's on hgh.
Hgh.
Oh definitely.
I mean he could.
Gregory could just look at somebody and
know whether or not they were like
toping and there were a time,
you know,
because I was on this program for a year
and he looks at me,
he's like,
but I ended up taking too much hgh
really.
So he cAn tell,
look,
do you know,
he is like looking at me and he's like,
you know,
seeing like your,
your,
your joel.
It's getting a little bigger,
your forehead,
these like you need to cut
down the dose voices perfect.
I mean he would,
it was just a,
you know,
he could just look at it
somebody and know,
like he just,
he,
just,
anybody he knew and we would meet people
over that year.
Um,
was a funny story when I was in moscow,
when I go to meet him after this haute
route,
whoa,
whoa.
Race and I,
and I bring with me,
which again,
we don't get into the film.
It's pretty crazy.
I'd had figured out essentially because
I wasn't going to be tested every day
that I was going to simulate the
protocol.
So during this,
the second race,
I'm pinging every single night into
ziploc bags and basically the ceiling,
the ziploc bag,
and storing this frozen urine unlike a
little thermos.
And the idea is as I'm going to bring
all my frozen urine with me to moscow
and I had all these blood tests done to
before,
after to build the biological passport
and the,
and the steroid profile.
Um,
so I bring him,
you know,
like all my,
all my frozen urine,
uh,
to moscow and uh,
and he had went into the process of,
of literally,
you know,
testing this,
this,
this urine that I'd brought them in,
ziploc bags that had smuggled with me
into,
into Russia.
And um,
and the second part of the investigation
comes out before he's able to covertly
test all of my urine within his lab,
which he shouldn't have been doing.
But I go to this birthday party and it's
the.
And in the film,
it's the,
it's.
I shot it on my iphone,
that scene of chaos with the birthday
party.
And he's there and he's singing and he's
introducing me and he's doing karaoke
and he's dancing.
So that party was for like a,
a russian gold metal,
like shot putter and everybody at that
party were like former gold metal shot
putters wrestling decathlon and these
weRe human giants.
And gregory was like,
yeah,
said
tim that told me was this.
He was a dentist,
he was not.
He was on this.
I mean it was every single person at
this party.
It was like,
I can't remember the names.
This is whatever.
This is motor yet that the daughter,
she won three olympic gold medals.
She was on duh duh,
dah.
Yes.
And we threw out there positive.
It was like,
it was every single if we were at this
party and there was like 30 of them and
I have these pictures of me with like
giants.
I mean literally like the biggest human
beings you've ever seen in your life.
and gregory's like,
yes,
it was.
Yes.
A helped him.
I helped him,
I helped him out.
Wow.
And,
and they were all now part of the sports
ministry.
Wow.
Yeah.
Listen man,
let's wrap this up.
Your documentary is fantastic.
A really enjoyed it and I really do
think it's probably the most powerful
anti-doping documentary ever made.
I think you,
you fucking nailed it.
It's really amazing and I really
appreciate you coming on here and I want
everybody to see it.
If you,
if you were interested in this stuff,
it's on netflix.
Icarus,
go check it out.
It is really,
really good.
Thank you brian.
Really appreciate it.
Thanks
joe.
And,
uh,
say to your listeners a,
anybody that wants to throw a bone to
gregory,
he's got a go fund me page and he could
really,
really use
that.
Go fund me pages on your twItter page.
It's on my twitter feed right now.
Um,
I posted a tweet today with the link to
his gofund me.
And uh,
if you go on,
go fund me and search for gregory
rodchenko,
you'll find it too.
But,
uh,
this is,
it's right there on my,
on my twitter at bryan fogel.
And uh,
yeah,
he's uh,
he's in some dire straits and uh,
really,
uh,
it's a,
it's a story that hasn't,
it's still unfolding its history.
We captured history and the history
involving the history is still unfolding
in the news in a,
in a daily basis,
so
it is,
but again,
you nailed it.
Really amazing work,
mate.
Thanks for having me on.
My pleasure.
All right folks.
We'll see you tomorrow.